Streich ist ein besonderer Trainer, ein besonderer Trainer, der jetzt seine Karriere beenden wird. Und darauf wollen wir hier zurückblicken im Rasenfunk. Und wir haben uns was ganz Spezielles einfallen lassen. Heute gibt es nämlich eine Kollaborationsfolge. Also das, was ihr jetzt dann gleich nach dem Intro hören werdet. Das ist eine Folge moderiert von Micha Tschirwa zusammen mit Patrick Röttele, beide vom Sportcast Freiburg. Denn der Sportcast hat ein riesiges Programm gemacht zum Abschied von Christian Streich. Und da dürfen wir vom Rasenfunk aus mitmachen. Das heißt, hier hört ihr jetzt dann einen Rückblick aus taktischer Sicht auf die Spielzeiten, die Christian Streich mit dem SC Freiburg hatte. Wir haben das zu dritt gemeinsam produziert. So ist es dann auch beim Sportcast zu hören. Und dort drüben bei denen, ich werde es natürlich alles verlinken in den Show Notes, da gibt es dann noch viel, viel mehr Informationen zum Abschied, noch viel mehr Aspekte der Persönlichkeit Christian Streichs. Hier ein taktischer Rückblick. Ich hoffe sehr, dieses Tribünengespräch gefällt euch. Und jetzt geht's los.
Das ist die erste Rasenfunk-Saison.
Ja, also vielleicht ist es auch noch eine Zeit, wo man ein bisschen begeistert ist vom Pressing auch, wenn man so taktisch interessiert ist. Aber es fängt schon an zu nerven, würde ich sagen. Genau, also These. Streich setzt die Entwicklung selber in Gang und wird Opfer dieser Entwicklung, weil er hält eben am flachen Aufbauspiel fest und läuft dann halt oft selber in Pressing der Gegenmannschaften. Und ich glaube, daran ist es letztendlich auch gescheitert. Würdet ihr dem zustimmen?
Ich schwanke. Ich weiß nicht, ob quasi die Rolle von Christian Streich da ein bisschen überbewertet wird hinsichtlich, weil er war ja nicht der Einzige, der diese Entwicklung in Gang gesetzt hat. Und wenn ich mich, also eigentlich müsste ich mich da jetzt sehr gut dran erinnern, weil ab dann haben wir Sendungen gemacht. Hier, 34. Spieltag, das Tuchelproblem der Liga mit Stefan Uesfeld und Tobias Escher. Also die Sendung muss ein Banger sein bei den Gästen, auch wenn ich als Moderator damals ganz, ganz fürchterlich war. Aber war, ich glaube, das war doch damals einfach so eine richtige Kack-Saison. Sorry, wenn ich das jetzt mal so sage. Aber die war auch nicht so arg interessant und attraktiv. Die Bayern sind über alle drüber gerollt. Das war super langweilig. Das war die Phase, wo es nur darum ging, holen sie jetzt endlich den Champions-League-Titel, haben sie nicht geholt. Oh Gott, Gott, Jola ist der Schlechteste überhaupt. Andere fangen an zu beutzen. Pardada, überhaupt nichts gegen ihn persönlich. Aber Pressing wird halt dann lang überspielt und vorne versucht man, die Tore zu machen. Und Schalke hat, glaube ich, auch ähnlich gespielt. Und ich hatte nicht das Gefühl, zumindest aus meiner Erinnerung, dass sich Freiburg da irgendwie taktisch einem Trend nicht mitgemacht hat. Also ja, klar, den Trend nicht zu, wir machen einen Matchplan für jeden Gegner. Das hast du ja gesagt, stur halt quasi so ein bisschen schon. Aber Freiburg ist gegen diese Dynamik dieser Saison, glaube ich, nicht angekommen. Und das war es eher. Und das war halt eher alles so, es war halt alles so wahnsinnig unnötig.
Jetzt haben wir hier die zwei Extreme. Patrick, du kannst vermitteln oder dich auf eine Seite schlagen.
Ich glaube, ich würde mich auf Maxs Seite schlagen. Aber aus diversen Gründen. Also einmal diese ganzen schweren Gegentore, ich glaube, die machen was mit einer Mannschaft. Ich habe für mich war es absolut verrückt, dass Bochum die letzten zwei Spiele in der aktuellen Saison gewonnen hat. Also 31 und 32, weil das für mich, also das hat so sehr 2015 getriggert, als sie beide Male nach der 3-0-Führung die Führung fast verspielt hätten, dass ich dachte, okay, das ist jetzt wie Freiburg damals. Und wenn man dann so einen Strudel hat in einer Saison mit späten Gegentoren, dann spielt man halt gegen Bundesligateams. Und wenn man dann so ein bisschen zweifelt, dann reicht das schon, dass man halt wieder zweifelt und dann wieder das Gegentor bekommt. Das war auf jeden Fall der Fall. Das war aber vor allen Dingen in der Hinrunde so. Ich glaube, das wird in der Rückrunde ein bisschen über erzählt, weil dieses Hamburg-Spiel am 32. Spieltag war. Da verliert man den Sieg, aber wegen einer Schiedsrichterentscheidung, die bis heute der Grund dafür ist, warum ich mit dem VAA ein bisschen was anfangen kann. Das ist ein absoluter Skandalpfiff. Egal. Und dann war aber glaube ich tatsächlich eher ein bisschen der Fall, dass man sich auch ab und zu ein bisschen zu sicher gefühlt hat. Man hatte eine sehr gute Phase Mitte der Hinrunde, nochmal Mitte der Rückrunde und war dann eigentlich nach dem Köln-Spiel Mitte der Rückrunde 14. Und es gab damals Berichte darüber, dass es das einzige Mal in der ganzen Streichzeit war, dass es in der Kabine nicht so richtig gestimmt hat. Also dass Streich auch danach, nach dieser Abstiegssaison, sehr viel Wert drauf gelegt hat, nochmal mehr als vorher mit allen Spielern zwei, dreimal zu sprechen über ihre Rolle und was es mit dem Team macht, wenn sie nicht spielen. Und dann hatte man das Gefühl, die Mannschaft trägt sich irgendwie selbst wieder an diesen Abstiegskampf rein. Dann hatte man ganz miese Auftritte und das Knackspiel, das Heimspiel gegen Paderborn, dass man absolut bodenlos gespielt hat und 2-1 verloren hat, völlig zu Recht. Und hat sich dann trotzdem nochmal rausgekämpft und gegen die Bayern gewonnen am vorletzten Spieltag und hat sich dann nochmal sicher gefühlt. Weil vor dem 34. Spieltag war eigentlich klar, es muss alles schiefgehen, dass man absteigt oder direkt absteigt. Und es ist alles schiefgegangen. Und irgendwie war dieses ganze Gemengelag in der Saison so, dass man, also man hat in vielen Spielen gesehen, dass diese Mannschaft eigentlich mit der Streichidee Punkte holen kann. Dass es mir zu kurz greift, diese Streichidee als Erklärung dafür zu nutzen, dass man absteigt. Also es gab sicherlich Probleme, dass man zu dogmatisch war. Aber es lag, glaube ich, auch einfach viel an einer Dynamik, einer Abstiegskampfsaison, die viel in der Mannschaft stattgefunden hat. Und ich hasse die Erklärungen immer, weil das ist halt immer schwammig. Weil das kann zwar nicht greifen, aber...
Aber hey, Fußball ist ja auch schwammig. Also ich glaube eben, das ist ja wirklich auch eine Sache, die man von verschiedenen Teams kennt. Ein Abstiegsstrudel, so eine Dynamik kann Teams runterreißen. Das würde ich auch auf jeden Fall gelten lassen. Okay, ihr werdet aber vielleicht noch sehen, wo mich das jetzt hinführt, meine These. Ich glaube, ein bisschen an ihr festhalten muss ich. Aber wir können es dann später nochmal besprechen. Habt ihr noch was zur Abstiegssaison? Oder wollen wir die langsam auch hinter uns lassen?
Ja, ich glaube, man muss nur nochmal betonen, wie das eben am letzten Spieltag war. Dass man eben aus dem Sieg gegen Bayern rauskommt. Und dass es wirklich, also es war jetzt nicht komplett vergleichbar mit dem Abstieg Nürnberg damals, 98, aber schon nah dran. Ich weiß noch, dass wir damals die HörerInnen tippen haben lassen, wie quasi das Abstiegsszenario sein wird. Und ich habe noch meinen Tipp hochgeladen, etwas, was ich heute nie machen würde, weil ich chronisch schlecht bin bei sowas. Aber da lag ich nämlich richtig, weil ich als Berufspessimist, und weil ich Freiburg eben einfach glaubte, zu kennen, es genauso getippt habe, wie es dann nämlich gekommen ist, dass nämlich alle gewinnen, die nicht gewinnen dürfen, und Freiburg dieses letzte Spiel verliert. Und es war damals schon dramatisch. Und wenn es einen badischen Günter Koch gäbe, dann wäre das auch, glaube ich, mehr im Fußballgedächtnis verankert.
Funfact für alle RasenfunkhörerInnen, weil die Spodcast-HörerInnen wissen das schon. Ich war damals auf Sky zu sehen, weinend im Block in Hannover.
Ja, das war schon bitter. Ich war mir nämlich letzter Spieltag, aber es war ja Pfingsten, glaube ich. Und dann war ich mit Freunden auf einer Hütte ohne Fernseher. Aber ich dachte auch nicht, dass noch was passiert. Deswegen, ich war nicht so pessimistisch. Naja, ja, scheiße gelaufen. Das kann man auf jeden Fall sagen. Und das wäre vielleicht auch nochmal ein Punkt von wegen dieses, warum man Streich vielleicht nicht irgendwie vorher entlassen hat oder so. Ich glaube, da würde ich euch jetzt wieder mehr Recht geben auch. Man hat eigentlich schon gesehen, das Team ist im Prinzip gut genug, um die Liga zu halten, mit einem Kader, der um den Abstieg sowieso mitspielen sollte. Und es gibt jetzt keinen Grund zu sagen, okay, mit Streich funktioniert das überhaupt nicht mehr oder so. Sondern es war halt schon sehr, sehr viel unglücklich einfach. Und da würde ich sagen, konnte man schon sehr gut nachvollziehen, warum man Streich irgendwie gehalten hat. Ja, und da würde ich dann auch sogar zur nächsten Saison springen. Ich mache kurz beides. Kurz Kontext, zweite Bundesliga. Also wir verlassen jetzt die erste Liga und gehen in die zweite Bundesliga. Nur, damit ihr das halbwegs vor Augen habt, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. In der zweiten Liga spielen damals noch 1860 München und Kaiser Slautern. Und es ist halt das, ich glaube, zweite Jahr von RB Leipzig. Ich glaube, das erste Jahr haben sie den Aufstieg nicht geschafft. Dieses Mal werden sie es schaffen, aber nur als zweite. Hinter dem glorreichen Sportclub aus Freiburg. Damals Leipzig mit Rangnick. Und wer schon im Team ist, sind Gulaschi, Selke, Paulsen, Klosemann, Orban, Khedira, also Rani Khedira und Forsberg. Also ein ordentlicher Zweitligakader, würde ich mal sagen. Aber auch Freiburg muss sich eigentlich im Kader her nicht verstecken. Das wusste man damals noch nicht, wie gut diese Spieler sind. Aber im Nachhinein konnte man das schon ganz gut sehen, weil hier wird der Kader für die nächsten Jahre gebaut. Es gehen zwar dann so Topspieler wie Derrida, Memedi, Bürki, Schmid, aber Petersen bleibt. War nicht ganz klar am Anfang, aber irgendwann kam die Nachricht, die glaube ich viele sehr euphorisiert hat. Und es kommen Niederlechner, Grifo, Kleindienst, Kübler und Abraschi. Philipp bleibt übrigens auch noch. Und meine These damals war ja, streichstogmatischer Ansatz mit 4-4-2, flacher Aufbau, hohes Pressing. Also der wird jetzt in der zweiten Liga gut funktionieren, weil man ist ja kadertechnisch überlegen und das müsste ja so einer Favoritenrolle sehr gut entgegenkommen. Dann ist aber halt was passiert, was ich damals nicht erwartet habe, nämlich nach zwei Minikrisen hat Streich tatsächlich den langen Ball eingeführt in der zweiten Liga. Also weil man dann eben manchmal doch zu ausrechenbar war, ging das dann, ja, hat Streich das dann irgendwie angefangen, so ich glaube, ab Mitte der Saison.
Ja, ich habe eine These dazu, die ein bisschen dazu passt, was wir später besprechen. Das ist auch das erste Mal, dass Streich einen taktischen Plan für einen Spieler ändert oder einen taktischen Plan ändert, weil er einen Spieler dazu bekommt. Weil die taktische Änderung geht damit einher, dass Florian Niederlechtner in diesem Winter nach Freiburg kommt. Es ist das erste Startelf-Spiel von Florian Niederlechtner, wo man das erste Mal lange Bälle schlägt, nämlich beim FSV Frankfurt. Damals startete man mit dem Doppelsturm wieder Niederlechtner GD, nachdem man die ganze Hinrunde Peters und Philipp gespielt hatte. Also schon ein deutlicher Stilbruch. Und nachdem man auch gerade mit GD, und das auch später mit Niederlechtner noch machen wird, auch einfach hohes Pressing spielen könnte, sagte er, okay, jetzt haben wir die athletischen Spieler, wo wir einfach Ball langschlagen, Ball jagen und dann aus den Räumen, wo wir die zweite Bälle gewinnen, da machen wir dann Umschatzsituationen draus. Das werden wir später diverse Male sehen. Kevin Schade wird eine Sonderrolle bekommen, Nico Schotterberg und so weiter. Das ist so vielleicht das kleine Beobachtung dazu. Ja, genau.
Voll gut. Also weil ich glaube, das könnte man vielleicht auch noch sagen, vorher dieses 4-4-2, das war halt auch ein wahnsinnig starres System, in dem Spiele eine bestimmte Rolle zugewiesen bekommen hatten, egal welcher Spiele dort oder dort gespielt hat, der musste diese Rolle halt ausfüllen. Also das war nicht so sehr auf die einzelnen Spiele zugeschnitten. Was glaube ich gerade für junge Spiele eine gute Sache ist. Also weil man so klar weiß, was man machen muss. Genau.
Und vielleicht noch ein Randaspekt, aber das rekonstruiere ich jetzt. Ich habe das nicht mehr in der Erinnerung gehabt, aber das ist ja eine der letzten Saisons von Julian Schuster, der ja immer so ein bisschen der verlängerte Arm von Christian Streich war im Zentrum. Und der fällt im Grunde die komplette Rückrunde aus und der macht insgesamt nur sehr, sehr wenige Minuten. Also ich könnte mir vorstellen, könnt ihr jetzt besser sagen, dass es auch daher kam, dass man vielleicht manchmal das eigene Mittelfeld gar nicht mehr in den Spielaufbau einbezogen hat.
Also absolut. Hätte man damals 2020er Nicolas Höfler gehabt, hätte man wahrscheinlich anders gespielt. Aber der wurde ja von Jahr zu Jahr besser, wie wir wissen.
Das stimmt tatsächlich, ja. Ich würde jetzt aber nochmal ganz kurz ein allgemeineres Thema ansprechen, Max, auch um dich reinzuholen, weil es gibt also zweite Liga. Man kennt es ja, dass es gibt so dieses Bild vom heilsamen Abstieg für Teams. Für Freiburg stimmte das ja, wissen wir jetzt im Nachhinein. Also tatsächlich hat man sich dort spielerisch weiterentwickelt. Man konnte die zweite Liga nutzen. Und einige Spieler, für die war das halt genau der richtige Zeitpunkt. Maximilian Philipp, Vincenzo Grifo, wen hatten wir noch? Also die beiden vor allem, aber auch für Höfler, Schwolo und so weiter, war das halt irgendwie ein guter Schritt, diese zweite Liga zu haben. Ist Freiburg da eine Sonderrolle?
Ich dachte, du willst quasi auf die Pointe raus, dass ja ein Absteiger, nämlich der SC Freiburg, Tabellen erster wurde und wieder hochgegangen ist. Und der andere Absteiger, der SC Paderborn, ist letzter geworden und ist durchgerauscht. Ja, voll gut. Das ist natürlich der absolute Kontrast zum SC Freiburg. Und der SC, glaube ich, ist mitverantwortlich für diesen Mythos, der ja dann vielleicht doch ein Mythos ist, was aber auch, glaube ich, wenn ich mich gerade richtig erinnere, daran liegt, dass man am SC Freiburg was sehen kann, was durchaus bei Absteigern vorkommt, nämlich das ganze Umfeld, inklusive Team und ZuschauerInnen, hat wieder Spaß am Fußball, weil man halt auch mal wieder gewinnt. Also Freiburg war damals halt sehr, sehr heimstark. Die haben nur zweimal zu Hause verloren, haben irre viele Punkte zu Hause. Hatten auch einen sehr, sehr guten ZuschauerInnenschnitt in der zweiten Liga und haben sehr, sehr viele Tore geschossen, sehr viele Punkte gemacht. Und das macht ja auch manchmal etwas mit einem Verein, wenn du manchmal sogar jahrelang gegen den Abstieg spielst, immer einen absoluten Mistfußball spielst und immer 1 zu 2 verlierst. Bei Freiburg ja oft noch in letzter Sekunde. Und das war definitiv auch in dieser Saison da. Aber mit Paderborn hattest du genau das Gegenbeispiel. Paderborn ist natürlich noch mal ein ganz anderer Verein, weil, dass die quasi überhaupt erste Liga gespielt haben, war ja schon überraschend. Und wir wissen ja, das war quasi so ein bisschen ihr Ding, durchzurutschen durch die zweite Liga, die nur so als Fasch zu verwenden. Aber damals hattest du diesen krassen Kontrast. Und ich weiß noch, dass sich damals viele gefreut haben, dass man eben vor Leipzig geblieben ist. Dass man diese Meisterschaft geholt hat und auch deutlich vor Leipzig geblieben ist mit fünf Punkten Vorsprung.
Ja, es gibt ja auch dieses berühmte Schneespiel, in dem Freiburg dann eben noch gewonnen hat. Auch 2-1 gegen Leipzig, das war, glaube ich, auch nicht ganz unwichtig.
Ich glaube, über die allgemeinere These vielleicht noch. Ich glaube, bei Stuttgart hat man gesehen, dass es funktionieren kann, dass man eine spielerische Idee in der 2. Liga aufbaut. Unter Matarazzo damals. Wobei da auch viel Tim-Walter-Einfluss noch mit drin war. Genau. Aber ich glaube, dass es heute ein bisschen weniger stimmt, weil ich schon häufiger darüber nachgedacht habe, dass Freiburg so ziemlich der letzte Absteiger war, wo es noch nicht ganz so sehr wehtart finanziell. Weil 2017 sind die TV-Gelder nochmal richtig explodiert. Damals ist das erste Mal das Ganze nicht nur an Sky gegangen, sondern in das Eurosport mit eingestiegen. Da hat man das erste Mal die Milliardengrenze geknackt. Inzwischen ist es, wenn jemand absteigt und er möchte mit einem guten Kader Zweite Liga spielen, geht er für das eine Jahr ins Risiko. Oder macht es halt nicht. Und dann hat man keinen so guten Kader. Und wenn du aber einen guten Kader zusammenhältst, dann bist du eigentlich fast gezwungen aufzusteigen. Deswegen wird es jetzt auch sehr spannend, was bei Hertha und Schalke nächste Saison passiert zum Beispiel. Dieser TV-Gelderverschnitt ist schon nochmal deutlich größer geworden als 2016.
Ja, und dann noch ein weiterer Aspekt, der dann aber eine Freiburg-Besonderheit ist. Da hat Freiburg vielleicht mehr als in anderen Saisons von dem eigenen Nachwuchskonzept profitiert. Weil du abgestiegen bist mit im Schnitt sehr jungen Spielern. Und da dann gar nicht so wirklich zur Debatte stand, dass da jetzt viele Leistungsträger gehen würden, sondern die das auch zum Teil als nächsten Schritt gesehen haben. Also, ich meine, Christian Günther ist da 22 Jahre alt. Entschuldigung, dass ich lache, aber das wird so. Marc-Oliver Kempf, 20 Jahre. Die machen die meisten Minuten hinten in der Abwehrreihe. Und, also da könnte man jetzt noch ganz viele weitere Beispiele nennen, aber die zwei stehen exemplarisch dafür. Und das hat Freiburg natürlich in dem Fall auch geholfen, weil andere Absteiger durchaus vier, fünf Spieler irgendwie zwischen 27 und 29 Jahren verloren haben, weil die auch einen ganz anderen Drang haben, in der ersten Liga zu bleiben oder dann nochmal einen anderen Vertrag mitzunehmen, den man vielleicht bekommen kann. Vielleicht war das auch so ein Unsung Hero eigentlich. Wir reden immer über die Spieler, die in der Erstliga sich dann etabliert haben und dann für viel Geld irgendwann gewechselt sind. Aber vielleicht war das auch ein wesentlicher Bestandteil davon, dass Freiburg so souverän durch diese Zweitligasaison durchgekommen ist, dass man einfach so einen jungen Kader hatte mit vielen Spielern, die da bleiben wollten und die dann auch eine ganz wichtige Rolle gespielt haben.
Ich zitiere mal Balak. Absolut. Es gibt nur einen Spieler, wo es mir wirklich weh tat. Das war der Rieder. Ich mochte den so gerne. Aber er war eine Nummer zu groß, um mitten in die zweite Liga zu gehen. Das fand ich schon sehr, sehr schade. Es steht am Ende der Aufstieg, wie ihr es jetzt beide schon gesagt habt. Ich glaube, ein Punkterekord, der bis heute nicht gebrochen ist, müsste ich auch noch mal nachschauen. Aber das war sehr, sehr gut. Springen wir in den weiteren Aufwärtstrend 16, 17 rein? Patrick, willst du den Kontext Bundesliga machen? Ich übernehme wieder mit dem Sportclub.
Voll gerne. Der nicht so schöne Teil Raber Leipzig spielt erstmals Bundesliga und wird direkt Vizemeister unter Ralf Hasenhüttl, der die Saison davor noch in Ingolstadt trainiert hatte. Das Bundesliga haben wir jetzt übersprungen mit Ingolstadt und Darmstadt.
Auch interessant eigentlich.
Bayern hat sein erstes Jahr unter Ancelotti, also gerade Jola ist im Sommer davor gegangen. Und unter Ancelotti sieht man sehr viel Hero Ball und wenig taktische Weiterentwicklung in München. Struktur schafft meistens Xabi Alonso, wenn es Struktur gibt.
Du frapes das völlig falsch. Damals hieß es, er hat die Fessin gelöst.
Ich erinnere mich, das erste Spiel gegen Bremen. Ja, genau. Dortmund kann Gündogan, Hummels und Meketaria nicht ersetzen, die alle in den Sommer gehen. Was Spannendes, was mir da noch mal aufgefallen ist. Johannes Tuchel ist der erste, also zumindest der erste, der es aktiv macht, der so eine hybride Dreier-, Viererkette spielt. Weil Gimta ist da noch in Dortmund und spielt viel Rechtsverteidiger in dieser Hinrunde. Er ist dann oft im Aufbau flach in der Dreierkette und der Linksverteidiger schiebt hoch. Guerrero damals, erste Saison in Dortmund. Genau, dann wird Hoffenheim im ersten Folienjahr in Nagelsmann vierter. Auch hier dominiert die Dreierkette mit ersten Hybridformen. Also die Dreierkette kommt so nach und nach richtig an in der Bundesliga. Und was man aber auch sagen muss, die Liga frisst nach wie vor Teams auf, die zwei Qualität haben, aber keine Struktur. Wolfsburg wird in der Saison 16. Rettet sich in der Relegation gegen Kiel. Ne, gegen Braunschweig damals. Leverkusen wird zwölfter. Am Ende in der Saison mit Typhoon Korkut. Trotz Harvats, Brandt und Bailey im Kader. Das ist auch absurd. Und oberes Mittelfeld in dieser Saison, da baue ich dir jetzt die Brücke, Micha, sind immer noch eher die stabilen Teams. Nämlich fünfter wird Köln-Unterstöger. Sechster die Hertha und der Dadai. Und siebter der SC Unterstreich, der dann in diesem Aufstiegsjahr wenig zu tun hat mit dem SC, den die Liga verloren hat, zwei Jahre vorher.
Ja, Freiburg wird siebter gleich beim Aufstieg. Der Stamm des Aufstiegsteams bleibt dann zusammen. Und der Kader wird sogar noch ein bisschen ergänzt. Also, tendenziell Arbeiter wie Gulde Bulut-Inyovski-Meffert, aber genau, so ein bisschen mit Haberer und Zyönsche, auch technisch anspruchsvolle Spieler. Wir haben jetzt irgendwie schon eingeführt. Streich ändert jetzt Dinge. Also, er hat den langen Ball eingeführt. Und jetzt kommt noch was Neues dazu, nämlich Streich experimentiert mit der Dreierkette. Ich glaube, war da nicht auch irgendeine Europameisterschaft oder Weltmeisterschaft, wo irgendwie die Dreierkette dann irgendwie deutlich stärker gespielt wurde. Ich glaube, Streich ist auch häufig von italienischen Teams begeistert gewesen und probiert es auf jeden Fall mal aus. Aber das wirkt erstmal noch sehr, sehr schematisch bei Freiburg. Also es ist jetzt noch nicht das, was wir später sehen werden und er kehrt dann auch relativ schnell zum 4-4-2 zurück. Auch einfach, weil es gut funktioniert. Es ist das Jahr mit diesem Job-Sharing Niederlechner-Petersen. Und Streich wird so ein Trainer, der mehr und mehr darauf achtet, dass Spieler, die eingewechselt werden, eine wichtige Rolle haben. Damals durfte man nur drei Spiele einwechseln, das muss ich immer noch dran erinnern, aber das hatte dann eben schon einen hohen Stellenwert einfach. Weiterhin viele lange Bälle, zweite Bälle, Niederlechner presst die Innenverteidigung müde, Petersen wird eingewechselt und macht das Tor. Das war das Job-Sharing. Genau. So. Dennoch, also naja, ich fange anders an. Ich glaube, wir können jetzt mal das Thema Grundlagen ansprechen. Max, du hast das Ganze im Anfang gesagt. Dass Streich für dich auch jemand war, der eben Grundlagen immer gut den Teams vermitteln würde. Und ich glaube, das ist hier so ein allgemeines Thema, was man hat, wenn man über Fußball spricht. Es geht häufig um Basics. Zwei Fragen dazu. Erstens, was sind denn Basics beim Fußball? Und genau, also welche Basics konnte Streich dann eben sehr gut machen? War er da einfach so stöger dadeimäßig oder genau, gab's noch gab's da bestimmte Konzepte?
Also der Basic oder die Grundlage, auf die alle Deutschen stehen, laufen. Du musst viel, viel laufen. Das war auf jeden Fall da. Und da war Streich aber gut darin, dass alle gleichzeitig laufen. Also es ging jetzt nicht darum, dass einer den Sprint anzieht und dann mit einer geilen Grätsche noch auch etwas auf das Deutsche sehr stehend im Bökel zumindest dann irgenbei klärt, sondern bei Streich kam die Laufleistung zustande, weil im Grunde immer alle in Bewegung waren. Und weil das Schiebeverhalten, Verschiebeverhalten von den Ketten einfach sehr aufeinander abgestimmt war. Und so kamen dann hohe Laufzahlen insgesamt zustande. Ich finde, dass Christian Streich auch jemand ist, der auf Passspiel sehr viel Wert liegt. Das war etwas, was über Tuchel und Gardiola fast sogar ein bisschen überbetont wurde. Und auch an solchen Dingen hat sich die Laptop- Trainer-Debatte entzündet, meiner Erinnerung nach. Es ging natürlich viel um Formationswechsel und Gardiola hat irgendwie viermal die Formation pro Spiel gewechselt. Aber es ging auch um so Sachen, wie das eben Thomas Tuchel gesagt hat, wenn jemand den Ball... Du musst den Ball immer mit dem Fuß annehmen, in die Richtung, in die du dann passen willst, weil du dann eben quasi kein Doppel, also weil du mit dem zweiten Kontakt passen kannst und nicht mit dem dritten Kontakt. Und du musst in der Körperstellung ein bisschen aufgedreht sein, wenn du eben einen gewissen Raum attackieren willst. Und über sowas konnte Thomas Tuchel damals sehr lange reden und hat das dann ja auch quasi nach Dortmund versucht zu bringen. Und das ist aber was, was, glaube ich, Christian Streich auch wichtig war. Man hat es nur damals nicht so gesehen, wenn ich mich gerade richtig erinnere, weil es war eben schon die... War das nicht die Zeit, wann war denn das Zitat, wir wolle den Ball haben?
Das war 13, 14 glaube ich. Also eine seiner ersten Saisons. Oder vielleicht sogar schon die erste Halbserie oder so.
Und ich glaube nämlich, dass es damals so war, zumindest meine ich mich so zu erinnern, dass wir das auch im Rasenfunk damals so besprochen haben. Ich glaube, Micha, du warst da auch schon das erste Mal im Rasenfunk mit dabei. Das hast nämlich du gesagt, das weiß ich noch ganz genau, dass ich angesprochen habe mit, ja, wir wolle den Ball habe, aber sie hatten ja irgendwie nur 30 Prozent Ballbesitz. Und dann hast du gesagt, ja du glaubst auch, dass er das so gemeint habe, wir wollen den Ball erobern. Also wir wollen den Ball von jemandem wegnehmen. Und ich glaube, in der Saison hat man das besonders gesehen, wenn ich jetzt nicht gerade komplett falsch liege.
Ja, also das würde ich schon auch sagen, dass da ist, dass es noch kein Fußball, wo es viel Ballbesitz gibt, sondern dass das Fußball mit Ball gewinnt, mit langen Bällen, mit zweiten Bällen, dann will man den Ball gewinnen, aber dann ist man auch immer schnell nach vorne und hat Abschlüsse gesucht. Also das ist auf jeden Fall der Punkt und da ist Niederlechner ja auch wirklich einfach der Paradespieler dafür, den man damals sich geholt hat. Deswegen würde ich schon auch sagen, wir wollen den Ball haben, heißt da eher, wir wollen den Ball jagen und dann ins Tor schießen und nicht wir wollen den Ball kontrollieren.
Ich glaube, wenn Streich von Basic spricht übrigens, meint, also er meint glaube ich nicht Laufleistung und Zweikämpfe, also es würde mich wundern, wenn er das meint. Ich habe eher das Gefühl, bei ihm ist es sehr viel. Wir machen jetzt keine Fehler, also wir versuchen nicht, wir versuchen nicht Aktionen zu kreieren, indem wir wild rausrücken, indem wir schwierige Pässe versuchen, sondern wir gehen auf die Basics zurück, wir spielen einfache Pässe, wir verschieben Ketten, wir stellen Spieler in den Deckungsschatten, wenn wir vorne anlaufen und gehen nicht auf Balleroberung, sondern wir machen die Basics-Sachen, um die Leute vom eigenen Tor wegzuhalten und entweder das geht 0-0 aus oder Grifo schlägt den Standard. Das ist glaube ich sein Basic-Gedanke.
Also Standards, das ist mir gerade auch aufgefallen, in der Vorbereitung habe ich das überhaupt nicht nachgeschaut, wie sich das mit den Standards entwickelt hat oder ob das eine Kontinuität ist, die sich durchzieht bis auf diese Saison. Dass die Standards immer gut sind, das ist eigentlich noch ein guter Punkt. Können wir auch nochmal darauf zurückkommen? Ich würde jetzt noch einen dritten Vorschlag bringen, was mit Basics eigentlich gemeint ist. Nämlich dieser Gedanke First Things First. Also bevor ich irgendwas fancy-mäßiges mache mit einer ich weiß nicht, mit irgendeiner besonderen Rolle für einen einzelnen Spieler oder dass wir besonders viel Ballbesitz haben, flach rausspielen oder sonst irgendwas, müssen wir erstmal eigentlich hier die Grundlage zusammen kriegen, dass wir überhaupt einen Spielaufbau gibt. Und wenn man und wenn das dann der lange Ball ist im Endeffekt, ne? Und wenn und wenn man das Gefühl hat, hohes Anlaufen funktioniert nicht gegen Bayern oder sonst irgendwas, dann muss man es eben erst ab dem Mittelfeld machen. Und wenn die ganzen Sachen funktionieren irgendwie, also wenn man es schafft, sich in ein Spiel reinzubeißen oder so, dann kann man vielleicht darauf aufbauen und sagen, ok, jetzt versuchen wir irgendwie spielerisch noch ein bisschen mehr zu machen. Und das war so ein Ansatz, den ich vielleicht auch bei Urs Fischer zum Beispiel gesehen habe. Da gab es manchmal spielerische Ansätze, wenn der Rest funktioniert hat. Aber vorher nicht. Oder bei Paul Daddard, das wäre auch so. Eigentlich da wäre es dann doch Klassiker. Wir können irgendwie häufiger mal risikohaft spielen, aber erst, wenn wir so eine Stabilität in unserem ganzen Spieldynamik haben, dass man darauf aufbauen kann. Und das denke ich ist bei Streich irgendwie schon auch immer so, diese Angst zu überpacen auch. Das ist auch eine vorsichtige Geschichte. Aber ich meine manchmal, ich weiß nicht, wir werden zu Peter Bosch bei Dortmund kommen oder so, da sieht man halt, was passiert, wenn man nicht diese basic Grundlage hat.
Und ich weiß aber noch, also um quasi, das ist jetzt wieder ein bisschen Bundesligakontext, aber ich glaube, es ist relevant. Wir hatten damals eine ähnliche Situation wie jetzt, nämlich, dass es quasi nach den ersten vier waren es damals, jetzt ist es nach den ersten fünf so einen krassen Cut in den Punkten gibt und dann ein sehr, sehr zusammengestauchtes Mittelfeld und es war im Grunde zwei Spieltage vor Schluss noch völlig unklar, wer in die Europa League einziehen würde. Und das war damals auch die Situation und da war eben Freiburg zusammen mit Köln und Hertha waren sie am glücklichen Ende, aber zwischen Platz 5 und Platz 9 waren es damals nur vier Punkte, also es hat sich eben quasi hinten raus dann erst entschieden. Und ich weiß noch, dass auch noch eine Diskussion damals war. Also zum einen würde über Sojunchi gesprochen. Das war nämlich die Saison, in der der SC Freiburg gezeigt hat, dass man wieder im Scouting eine neue Idee hat. Und jetzt waren es halt nicht irgendwie die ganzen Willys, die man geholt hat, sondern mit Sojunchi hat man damals an einem Ort gescoutet, an dem zwar andere Vereine waren, die aber noch nicht bereit waren, diesen Transfer zu machen. Also dass da auch andere Vereine waren, das weiß ich, weil das in Tobis Buch steht, was Teams erfolgreich macht. Da hat er mit, glaube ich, Clemens Hattenbach genau über diesen Transfer auch gesprochen. Und der ist ja damals eingeschlagen wie nichts, war richtig gut, aber jetzt haben wir den Vorteil, dass ich ab jetzt auch Rasenfunk-Dokumente konsultieren kann. Und ich habe hier zum Beispiel im Rasenfunk Royal damals darüber gesprochen. Also zum einen, dass das ein wilder Start in die Saison war, aber vor allem nur Bremen und Darmstadt hatten damals mehr Schüsse aufs eigene Tor zugelassen und nur Hamburg und Darmstadt haben weniger Schüsse aufs gegnerische Tor abgegeben. Also sprich, die Effizienz, die man hatte durch Niederländer, Lechner 11 Tore, Petersen 10 Tore, Maximilian Philipp 9 Tore, Grifo 6 Tore plus eben 8 Vorlagen, übrigens noch nicht durch Standards. Standards, da waren wir irgendwie Franken 13 damals in der Liga. Das war damals so ein Talking Point, den man wieder und wieder bei Freiburg hatte. Haben die nicht einfach sehr viel Glück? Also so ein bisschen das, was später da mit Union auch häufig kam, dass man gesagt hat, Mensch, eigentlich dürften die doch gar nicht so gut sein. Das hat zu dieser Saison auch dazugehört, aber man hatte ja auch zum Beispiel eine Tordifferenz von minus 18 und ist damit siebte geworden.
Der Füchsel-Talk, ne? Mit dem Hashtag Don't mention the Tordifferenz.
Nee, leider nicht mehr.
Ja, vielleicht ist es... Nee, eigentlich ist es noch zu früh dafür, aber Max hat gerade gesagt, die drei drittmeisten Schüsse aufs Tor zu gelassen. Wir werden dann häufiger drüber sprechen. Ich weiß, dass das unsere Spodcast-Zeit sehr geprägt hat, die fünfeinhalb Jahre bisher, dass Freiburg immer viele Schüsse aufs Tor zu gelassen hat und dass Torhüter immer sehr gute Paradenquoten hatten, aber oft gar nicht so schwierige Schüsse abwehren mussten. Ich würde aber sagen, die Saison 16-17 ist dafür noch nicht das perfekte Beispiel, weil da steuert man es auch nicht. Das passiert eher später, wenn Robin Koch und Philipp Lin in Erscheinung treten.
Ja, aber ich würde wirklich gerne da nochmal reingretschen, weil ich glaube, also, erstmal kann man vielleicht festhalten, zur Abstiegssaison und zu dieser Saison es gibt Parallelen. Nämlich, es sind sau viele knappe Spiele und in der Abstiegssaison hat man die dann alle irgendwie verloren. Und in dieser Europa League Saison hat man die dann irgendwie sehr, sehr häufig knapp gewonnen. Und ich glaube, an der Torreferenz kann man sehen, es kann halt echt in die eine und die andere Richtung kippen. Das zeigt erstmal eigentlich, wie brutal dieses Bundesliga-Mittelfeld ist. Und dass man halt ein bisschen so oder so an einem Ende landen kann. Was jetzt aber als weichen Faktor irgendwie noch dazuzählen würde, warum das vielleicht, also warum man einmal an dem einen und einmal an dem anderen Ende gelandet ist, wäre die Idee, dass sich Streich eben deutlich stärker auf dieses Spiel um die Strafräume konzentriert hat und nicht so sehr eben dieses komplette Spiel, also durch die langen Bälle und so, hatte man halt, glaube ich, eine ganz andere eine ganz andere Verteilung von den Angreifern vorne, die sich nicht so viel ins Aufbauspiel einbinden mussten und dann vorne sich halt wirklich auch auf die wesentlichen Sachen konzentrieren konnten, nämlich geile Kombinationen zum 16er und dann einen guten Abschluss, was mit Philipp und Niederlechnern so gut funktioniert hat Und dass aber auch die Innenverteidiger sich halt aufs Wesentliche konzentrieren konnten und nicht immer die Konzentration im eigenen Ballbesitz total hochhalten müssen, hier spiel ich wieder einen krassen Pass, der daneben gehen kann und hier spiel ich wieder einen krassen Pass, sondern die es halt auch einfach machen durften, den Ball nach vorne schlagen, das was halt krimmerscht und so weiter nicht machen durften. Und dass das eben dann im Endeffekt auch dazu führt, dass man vielleicht in den wichtigen Punkten dann da ist, in den wichtigen Zonen auch um die Strafräume herum und das dann dazu geführt hat, dass ein bisschen besser ausgegangen ist als in der Abstiegssaison.
Und was war die wichtigste Frage, die gestellt wurde damals im Rasenfunk Royal von DOI 92, wird man absteigen in der nächsten Saison? Und da hat es damals rausgesucht, die Europapokalsaison, eben 2001, 2002 Abstieg, 2013, 2014 Klassenerhalt und 1995, 96 auch Klassenerhalt. Also auch damals schon die alles beherrschende Frage. Oh Gott, steigt die jetzt ab in der nächsten Saison? Wollen wir sie auflösen, die Frage? Sind sie abgestiegen?
Man ist in Juli ausgestiegen, deswegen ist das nicht so richtig die perfekte Verantwortung.
NK Dom Schale schießt Freiburg aus der Euro-Quali raus, Mann, Tim Kleindienst auf dem Flügel, das war alles ärgerlich. Aber genau, lass uns über die Brücke drüber gehen, es sind noch ein paar Saisons. Wir steigen mal ein bisschen aufs Gaspedal. Machst du die Bundesliga?
Jo, es ist keine schöne Bundesliga-Saison. Max hat gerade von dem großen Loch zwischen Platz 4 und Platz 5 gesprochen. Da ist es dann ein sehr großes Loch von Platz 1 bis Platz 2. Bayern hat noch bis September Carlo Ancelotti, dann kommt Heinkes zurück und dominiert die Liga. Schalke wird Vizemeister und Tegesco mit 64 Punkten. Ich weiß, würde man damit dieses Jahr Sechster werden? Wahrscheinlich. Das ist relativ realistisch wahrscheinlich. Dortmund hat die Bosch-Stöger-Saison und diese Qualität der Liga, ich habe das glaube ich nur das eine einzige Mal rausgesucht, aber das steigt sich auch international wieder, weil da ist man historisch schlecht. Nur die Bayern überstehen die eigene Gruppe in der Champions League, Hoffenheim und Köln scheiden in der Europa League-Gruppe aus, Stuttgart erreicht dann auch mit einem späten Teil von Korkut-Run fast Europa, Bayer Leverkusen hat die ganz schlimme Heiko Herlichzeit, auch das hatte ich verdrängt. Man muss ehrlich sagen, wenn man sich die Tabelle und die Trainer anguckt, das einzige spannende Team in der ganzen Liga ist Hoffenheim unter Jule Nagelsmann, glaube ich. Frankfurt gewinnt ein Pokal unter Kovac, aber Frankfurt-Kovac war jetzt auch taktisch nicht unbedingt spannend.
Aber das war die Champions-League-Saison, wo Hoffenheim sich quasi für die Champions-League qualifiziert hat. Damals hinter einem sehr, sehr schwachen Schalke 04. Damals hatten wir die Zeiten, wo dann die ersten Prominenten im Rasenfunk aufgetreten sind. Da habe ich mit Jan Henke und Matthias Sammer gesprochen. Er hat gesagt, dass Schalke mit diesem Fußball weiter wird. Das liegt an der Liga. Das wurde dann zitiert und damals heiß diskutiert. Damit wurden dann Schalke-Verantwortliche konfrontiert. Das war interessant.
Für Freiburg ist es eine Saison, das ist jetzt ein bisschen schwierig. Da wird gleich meine Frage auch darauf hinzählen. Erstmal, was passiert auf dem Transfermarkt? Grifo und Philipp verlassen den Verein. Schon hart, muss man sagen. Das waren schon die beiden herausragenden Spiele. Und da funktionieren diverse Flügeltransfers nicht. Sie kommen, aber sie funktionieren nicht. Ist das die Hündesaison auch? Habe ich jetzt ganz kurz aufgeschrieben. Aber man wollte Cengiz Hünde und hat den nicht bekommen. Okay, es kommen Kapuschka, Ravée, Terrazino, Kent. Na ja, hat alles nicht so funktioniert. Aber es kommen halt auch Robin Koch, Philipp Linard und Lukas Höhler ab dem Winter dann. Und hier, also taktisch ist es eine interessante Saison, weil Streich schafft es jetzt, die Dreierkette umzusetzen und wird auch ziemlich flexibel. Hier hat Schuster nochmal so einen Innenverteidiger Revival, also dass er als zentraler Innenverteidiger Libero kommt. Genau, und halt oft so nach vorne pendelt. Und Franz aus dem 6er-Bereich dann nach vorne pendelt in den Angriff. Es gibt da auch einen Spielverleihungsartikel von Tim Rieke, glaube ich. Da steht Streich, ich kenne auch 514. Also das war interessant und da wurde Streich flexibler. Es ist auch die Saison, in der es diese Taktik-Schlacht mit Nagelsmann gab, in der die halt in den ersten 25 Minuten so dreimal ihre Formation umstellen, ohne auszuwechseln. Das war dann irgendwie so. Gibt es auch einen Spielverleihungsartikel von Tobias Escher jetzt dazu, der sagt dann auch, das ist jetzt ein bisschen übertrieben, aber das wird selbst den Spielverleihungsleuten zu wild. Allerdings, Franz verletzt sich am 11. Spieltag und danach wird es nicht mehr so interessant taktisch. Also es gibt dann die Dreierkette, aber nur noch in sehr defensive Form. Und das wird eine harte Saison. Ein Highlight-Spiel, das ich noch kurz erwähnen möchte, haben wir letztens im Rasenfunk auch noch mal uns daran erinnert. Gemeinsam das 3-4 in Köln, dieses Schneespiel, das es da gab. Jetzt, Max, deine Erinnerung möchte ich anzapfen. Es gibt da genau diese beiden Bilder von Streich. Das eine ist dieses taktisch flexible Ding mit Nagelsmann und es gibt das, ich weiß nicht, ob dich daran noch erinnerst, am Ende so viel Verletzte. Und er haut so ein 5-4-1 gegen Mainz raus im vorletzten Spieltag, glaube ich, mit so richtig Abstiegskampf. Es ist nur defensiv, kaum Tore aus dem Spiel raus. Nur Petersen rettet dieses Team irgendwie noch über den Strich. Welches Bild von Streich ist dir da im Kopf geblieben eigentlich?
Also, ich will jetzt nicht so tun, als ob ich zu jeder Saison klares Streich im Kopf habe. Aber ich weiß noch, dass dieser Trend so irre negativ war. Und das ist also die ganzen Verletzungen, dann hatte man noch WAA, Pech. Ich kann nicht mehr genau sagen, was das Pech war. Ich habe es nur im Rasenfunk-Royal-Dokument gesehen. Patrick erinnert sich noch.
Halbzeit 11 Meter in Mainz, das war damals das Ding. Der Schiedsrichter war schon in den Katakomben.
Stimmt, nein, nein, nein, der Schiedsrichter, er hatte, er war noch auf dem Spielfeld, weil nur deswegen durfte er die Teams aus den Katakomben wieder rausrufen.
Aber ich meine, das wurde spezifiziert, er war noch auf dem Spielfeld, als der Kontakt begonnen hat, aber der Schiedsrichter war dann schon in den Katakomben. Genau, das war verrückt.
Und die erste VR-Rote auch gegen Jure Gravé.
Und war das auch das Spiel, wo Nils Petersen nicht mitbekommen hat, in Anführungszeichen, dass er eine erste Gelbe gesehen hat?
Ja, genau, und durfte dann gegen Wolfsburg stattdessen spielen, aber man hat trotzdem verloren. Also es war, die Rückrunde war richtig mies.
Und man hat es halt wirklich nur mit einem Heimspiel gegen Köln, die als 18er schon angereist sind, man hat knapp 3 zu 2 gewonnen und dann diesen 2 zu 0 in Augsburg irgendwie noch geschafft. Also prägend ist da nichts mehr geblieben. Aber ich weiß nicht, ob Seuchensaison zu hoch gegriffen ist, aber da lief auch wahnsinnig viel schlecht für Freiburg und das ging im Grunde schon los mit dem Ausscheiden in der Quali im Europapokal und dann eben mit diesen Verletzungen, mit diesen komischen Geschichten. Also dieses 4 zu 3 in Köln, das ist ja ein Spiel, was man gewonnen hat, muss man ja sagen. Letztlich hat man sechs Punkte gegen Köln geholt, die auch, sagen wir, klanglos als 18. abgestiegen sind in der Saison. Das war ja auch deswegen so herausstechend, weil es so eins der guten Spiele von Freiburg war in dieser Saison. Weil auch dieses Taktikgewichse gegen Nagelsmann, also ich zitiere hier sogar Tobias Escher, der hat später nochmal darüber gesprochen. Es war ja auch ein eins zu eins. Es war irgendwie eine graue Saison mit weiter vielen Gegentreffern und sehr wenigen eigenen Toren. 32 Tore.
Vielleicht noch kurz, um das für das Richtung Fazit zu überlegen. Das ist ja so ein bisschen typisch für Streich, wie ich das im Kopf habe. Wenn Transfers nicht früh funktionieren und so was und dann ein paar schlechte Sachen kommen, dann hatte Freiburg auch üble Saisons. Rechnet man ihm das dann hoch an, dass er es trotzdem irgendwie noch geschafft hat? Oder sagt man auch, vielleicht hätten das andere Trainer besser hinbekommen? Also hier so Streich als so Elendsverwalter oder so. Was für ein Gefühl habt ihr dazu? Weil mir fällt es enorm schwer, eigentlich zu sagen, ob Streich überhaupt der Richtige immer dafür war in diesen miesen Saisons. Also in diesen Saisons, in denen es so viel Gegenwind gab. Das will ich sagen. Ich will nicht sagen, dass er das mies gemacht hat, sondern ja.
Ich glaube, es ist schwierig zu beantworten, weil Streich eigentlich in schlechten Phasen immer das Gleiche gemacht hat. Erst wenn es schlecht lief, ist er vorsichtiger geworden. Immer. Also eben du hast dieses Spiel in Mainz angesprochen. 3-4-3, defensiver Außenverteidiger plus Kochhöfler im Mittelfeld und dann waren die offensiven Flügel, Höhler und Haberer. Kein lecker Bissen sieht man schon an der Aufstellung. Und er hat das ja immer gemacht über die Saisons hinweg. Und wenn man halt zwei, drei Spiele verloren hatte, man ist wieder zu einem defensiven System zurück und man hat das Spiel dann 1-0 gewonnen, dann hat man danach gedacht, ach, Streich hat alles richtig gemacht. Aber gerade diese Saison, also man hatte die Phase vom 13. bis zum 24. Spieltag in elf Spielen einen in der Lage. Sonst super gute Spiele auch teilweise. Da war Tim Klein-Dienst zwischendurch richtig cool Ende der Hinrunde. Und dann hatte man aber halt einfach eine Phase, wo man über Wochen hinweg nicht gewonnen hat. Und Streich wurde immer defensiver und es hat immer schlechter funktioniert. Und das fühlt sich als Fan dann richtig schlimm an, weil ich sehe jetzt hier gerade dreimal in Folge 0-2 und dann einmal 0-1. Da verlierst du als Fan lieber einmal 4-2 und hast das Gefühl, hey, da kann offensiv mal was passieren, als wenn du dich so in einen Trott reinverwaltest in einer langen Serie. Das war die miese Saison, die ich in der aktiven Erinnerung als SC Fan habe tatsächlich. Und ich habe zwei Abstiegssesons miterlebt, aber das sticht für mich hier raus. So ist miese Saison.
Aber andererseits, und das hast du ja eingangs wunderbar noch mal herausgehoben, das war auch eine richtig bekackte Bundesligasaison. Entschuldigung für meine Sprache hier an dieser Stelle. Du hast ja vorhin schon die entsprechenden Namen genannt. Ich habe jetzt noch mal geguckt, wie viele Trainerwechsel gab es eigentlich. Weil eigentlich müsste man erwarten, rund um Freiburg haben alle ihre Trainer entlassen, weil da eigentlich alle Mies gespielt haben. War aber gar nicht so sehr. Also Wolfsburg ist irgendwie von Jonker zu Martin Schmidt zu Bruno Labbadia gehöpft. Klar, warum auch nicht. Hat ja auch für die Relegation dann gegen Braunschweig gereicht. Der HSV von Gistol zu Hollerbach zu Titz und Köln von Stöger, aber das war quasi schon der Ende der Hinrunde. Und dann drei Tage später sitzt er bei Dortmund auf der Bank und Stefan Rutebeck hat da die Saison fertig gemacht. Und dann hattest du aber eben noch so Trainerwechsel, die sehr gut funktioniert haben. Und da war Christian Streich quasi der Kontrast dazu. Also Freiburg hat festgehalten an Streich. Es lief aber wirklich nicht gut. Wir haben seit, wir wollen es jetzt auch nicht überbetonen, aber es war halt schlecht. Aber Werder Bremen zum Beispiel wechselt von Alexander Nouri zu Florian Kohfeldt. Und der VfB Stuttgart, du hast es vorhin schon gesagt, die kommen mit Teil von Korkut als Rückrundenzweiter, glaube ich. Dann eben auf dem sechsten Tabellenplatz. Die gehen weg von Hannes Wolf, einem sehr talentierten Trainer und so weiter. Erinnert man sich ja noch so grob, warum der dann damals gegangen ist. Und Freiburg war eigentlich dann so die graue Maus. Sie bleiben halt bei Christian Streich, aber im Grunde hat keiner gute Laune. Aber sie bleiben halt auch drin.
Und Streich selbst die schlechteste Laune von allen. Das war auch eine Sache, die immer schwer war. Das Streich hat einem jetzt auch im Abschiebskampf nie so ein gutes Gefühl geben, sondern die Pressekonferenzen waren auch wahnsinnig deprimierend.
Der Sommer war der, das hatte er danach auch in Medien gesagt, der, wo er am meisten drüber nachgedacht hat aufzuhören bis jetzt zu diesem Sommer. Das war nämlich der Sommer, in dem Freiburg Kontakt mit Salt Löw hatte. Als damals schon Tuchel-Kotrenner. Da wäre damals nämlich Streich-Nachfolger geworden, wenn er 2018 aufgehört hätte.
Darf ich als Übergang in die neue Saison einen Kommentar vorlesen, den wir damals bekommen haben im Forum, beziehungsweise vielleicht war das sogar noch einfach in dem Google-Dokument. Das lief damals noch anders beim Rasenfunk. Damals hat Pischty geschrieben, Zitat, die goldenen Zeiten sind vermutlich vorbei. Eine ordentliche Fußballschule und Nachwuchsarbeit sind kein Alleinstellungsmerkmal mehr, dass man dort wenig bezahlen kann und will ein Nachteil, auch wenn es als Pädagogik verkauft wird. Die Talente werden tendenziell von den Retorten-Clubs abgegraben, die daran ein Geschäftsmodell sehen und mit Infrastrukturpunkten können. Nicht ohne Grund waren unter den letzten in Anführungszeichen Stars der Freiburger Fußballschule oder des Vereins ja tendenziell Ehrspieler, die woanders nicht mehr gewollt waren, die man aber doch entwickeln konnte, beispielsweise Grifo und Philipp. Aber mehr ist nicht geblieben. Dass der SC finanziell abgehängt ist, als letzter Bundesligist erst einen Ärmessponsor gefunden hat, den kommunalen Stromversorger, das Stadion auf sich warten lässt, sind weitere Symptome, dass außer dem Biotop-Charakter kaum noch Alleinstellungsmerkmale übrig sind. Und was sollen wir sagen? Er hatte in allen Punkten recht, er oder sie. Oder etwa nicht?
Wirklich interessant.
Aber das war der Vibe damals.
Ich glaube, aber auch das mit den eigenen Talenten ist halt wirklich ein guter Punkt. Ich meine, das kommt jetzt gerade wieder so krass, aber da gab es schon eine kurze Durststrecke dazwischen. Oder kamen die Schlotterbecks erst in der Saison oder erst danach?
Die sind ja eigentlich ein gutes Beispiel dafür, dass der Kommentar ein Stück weit recht hat, auch wenn er es komplett verschärft. Aber Freiburg stellt ungefähr um den Zeitraum auch das Jugendscouting um. Also man ist, nachdem man in den Jahren davor sehr viel damit hadert, dass die eigenen Top-Talente alle irgendwann nach Hoffenheim gehen, weil die in der U15 schon Geld dann bezahlen, fängt man dann selber an, relativ früh auch an Jugendspielern dran zu sein. Man hat jetzt auch viele, die aus der Region kommen, aber zu den Letzten aus der Fußballschule. Kevin Schade kam aus Cottbus, Kylian Zidlija aus Metz, Merlin Röhl aus Ingolstadt, sogar schon nach einer Zweitligasaison. Die Schlotterbecks kamen relativ spät nach Freiburg. Also man hat darauf auch reagiert, dass man eben nicht mehr allein das Alleinstellungsmerkmal hatte. Also es gab schon Grund zu Pessimismus damals, im Sommer 2018. Man konnte ja auch nicht ahnen, dass man aus fast allem die richtigen Schlüsse ziehen wird in den Jahren darauf.
Sehr interessant. Ich mache 18, 19 einfach zusammen kurz. Kontext, Bundesliga, das kann man schnell machen. Das ist wirklich langweilig an der Spitze. Es sind Kovac-Bayern, Rangnick Leipzig. Vielleicht, wenn man auf so defensiv Fußball steht, ist Rangnick Leipzig vielleicht interessant. Favre Dortmund immer so halb. Und das Bayer Leverkusen und der Bosch war vielleicht noch halbwegs interessant. Und ich mochte Hütte Frankfurt ja eigentlich gerne. Die hatten so eine eigene Energie, was sie nach vorne bringen konnten. Okay, was aber 18, 19 passiert ist, vor allem Düsseldorf wird 10. mit Funke. Sehr interessant. Und Schalke kommt mit der Doppelbelastung nicht klar, habe ich geschrieben. Kurz Doppelbelastung. Stimmt das? Ja klar, stimmt das. Ja und die retten sich auch mit Stevens und interessant ist da vielleicht noch, dass Stuttgart in die Relegation geht und diese verliert gegen Union Berlin. Die kommen danach. Okay, was passiert mit Freiburg? Wir hatten gerade darüber gesprochen in der Saison davor, war es eine schlechte Transferperiode. Jetzt ist so eine Transferperiode wie aus dem Buch. Also es kommen sehr, sehr früh Waldschmidt, Schallay, Heinz, Flecken, Gondorf und Lienhard wird festverpflichtet, glaube ich. Und ganz am Ende kommt dann noch die Kirsche auf dieses Sahnehäubchen. Grifu kommt zurück. Das ist dann, glaube ich, da, das ist jetzt eben der Kader, wie wir ihn heute kennen, wird dort praktisch hingebastelt, würde ich sagen. Es ging aber Söhn, Schö und Kämpf schon auch schon auch hart. Aber irgendwie jetzt bekommt Freiburg so einen guten Innenverteidiger. Nach dem nächsten habe ich das Gefühl, die sie dann ausbilden und verkaufen. Okay, nach dieser Transferperiode könnte man wahrscheinlich zum ersten Mal wieder so ein bisschen entspannter gewesen sein, dass man mit dem Abstieg vielleicht nichts zu tun hat. Also ich glaube, ich habe da auch zum ersten Mal getippt, dass es wahrscheinlich gut funktionieren wird. Und Streich, also was da taktisch passiert, ist schon, dass er eigentlich diese Ansätze von letzten Jahr jetzt weiter ausbaut. Also es wird wieder flexibler von Informationen, nicht mehr ganz so wild hin und her, aber Dreierkette, Viererkette. Es werden weiterhin, sind diese Pressing-Pläne im Fokus, würde ich sagen, was man gegen den Ball macht und das Mannschaftstaktische ist im Fokus. Aber es passiert auch mehr mit dem Ball. Und gerade, ich finde, eigentlich sieht man es ganz gut an Walsch mit. Das ist halt ein Spieler, der für Spielkultur steht und stand bei Freiburg.
Genau.
So, ich habe hier gar keine Frage aufgebaut, wie viel da wird Freiburg. Freiburg spielt halt eine okaye Saison, wirklich. Also das habe ich noch gut in Erinnerung. Freiburg spielt eine okaye Saison. Am Ende versucht man, noch mal mehr spielerisch zu machen, aber das klappt dann nicht so gut. Am Ende, am Ende kriegt man es nicht mehr so perfekt hin. Und dann wird man halt irgendwie locker, also so locker im Tabellenmittelfeld. Aber es ist der Auftakt von einer jetzt wirklich guten Phase von Freiburg.
Und es ist aber noch, glaube ich, eine der Saisons, wo es einen Unterschied gab zwischen Leuten, die alle Freiburg-Spiele sehen und vielleicht auch dem Verein verbunden sind und der Außensicht auf Freiburg. Weil nämlich diese spielerischen Ansätze, die du jetzt angesprochen hast, mit Luca Waldschmidt, da musste man schon genau hingucken, um die zu sehen. Und ich erinnere mich auch jetzt, das war die erste Saison, in der du zu Gast warst, Micha, und nämlich auch dieses Zitat gesagt hast. Und ich habe auch hier nämlich nochmal in jetzt meine Notizen nach der Saison quasi für den Royale reingeblickt. Und da siehst du eben zum Beispiel bei den langen Bällen Platz 3 hinter Wolfsburg und Mainz die fünf meisten Abschlüsse nach Umschaltsituationen hinter Frankfurt, Leverkusen, Düsseldorf und Dortmund. Man war auf Platz 17 bei den Dribblings und man hatte am zweitwenigsten Ballbesitz, 45 Prozent im Schnitt sogar noch aufgerundet. Also sprich, es war schon noch viel gegen den Ball arbeiten, lang den Ball nach vorne bringen, aber es gab halt schon so Elemente. Aber diese Übergangsphase, die wir jetzt dann glaube ich dann in der Folgesaison vor allem dann besprechen werden, dass man eben auch ein konstruktives Spiel nach vorne aufbaut und es eigentlich egal ist, ob man den Ball hat oder den Ball nicht. Das war in der Saison in einzelnen Spielen schon zu sehen. Ich weiß noch, dass wir da noch drüber gesprochen haben im Rasenfunk. Also wir zwei und auch mit anderen Gästen und ich denke auch im Royale war es noch ein Thema. Aber von außen betrachtet war es schon relativ bieder mit immer noch vielen Gegentoren. Aber es waren halt interessante Spieler mit dabei.
Man könnte vielleicht in der Saison noch sagen, dass es, du hast es ein bisschen gesagt, mit Pressingplänen. Es gibt wieder mehr Fokus auf Spiel gegen den Ball vorne. Das war im Jahr davor wenig, da hat man viel tief verteidigt. Direkt nach dem Aufstieg war es so ein bisschen anders. Jetzt aber komplett anders als in den Anfangszeiten. In den Anfangszeiten war das offensive Anlaufen darauf ausgelegt, Bälle zu erobern, um dann daraus auszuschalten, äh, umzuschalten. Und in 18, 19 ist Freiburg vielleicht die erste Saison richtig gut darin, den gegnerischen Sechser aus dem Spielaufbau rauszunehmen. Da reden wir in Freiburg sehr viel über Deckungsschatten. Ähm, da ist dann Lukas Höhler ab dem Moment eigentlich nicht mehr wirklich wegzudenken aus der Mannschaft. Da rotiert dann die Offensivbesetzung um ihn herum, aber Lukas Höhler spielt immer. Ähm, und es gibt auch einfach kein Freiburgspiel mehr, wo man dieses Wort Deckungsschatten vermeiden kann, weil es Christian Streich auch in jeder Pressekonferenz betont, um ehrlich zu sein. Ähm, da, da ist man dann sehr darin, wo lenkt man den Gegner hin, aber nicht wo lenkt man den Gegner hin, um dann zuzupacken, sondern einfach wo lenkt man den Gegner hin, um ihn nicht in eigene gefährliche Räume zu essen. Ähm, das sorgt dann dafür, dass die Spieler eigentlich einfach nicht so spektakulär sind, weil ich weiß auch noch, dass wir damals sehr, sehr häufig die Diskussion hatten, eben auch mit Fans von gegnerischen Teams, die Freiburg nicht häufig sehen, denen dann immer gesagt haben, ja, okay, ihr habt gegen uns gewonnen, aber wir hatten heute auch einen super schlechten Tag. Und das haben halt irgendwie 17 andere Teams so geschrieben, weil Freiburg es halt damals echt sehr gut geschafft hat, die Gegner schlecht aussehen zu lassen, ohne dabei aber selbst so oft sehr gut auszusehen, um ehrlich zu sein.
Man hat die Gegner auf sein Niveau runtergezogen. Das war also das, was wir damals oft gesagt haben. Und das hat sich nämlich gerade in Spitzenspielen gezeigt. Gegen die ersten fünf der Tabelle hat man nur gegen Dortmund verloren. Also Bayern, Dortmund, Leipzig, Leverkusen, Gladbach waren die ersten fünf der Tabelle. Und das waren immer ganz langweilige Spiele.
Ich erinnere mich aber auch noch, ich glaube, das ist auch so ein bisschen die Phase, in der ich wirklich Spaß an diesen Pressingplänen habe. Und es ist auch, glaube ich, genau das Spiel gegen Leverkusen, in dem Korten Havertz in Mandeckung nimmt. Und so kam irgendwie, also Streich hat sich wirklich da. Also da konnte man auch sehr, sehr viel beobachten. Man konnte dann irgendwie anschauen, aber klar, wenn man sich das dann die ganze Zeit anschaut und Fan dieses Teams ist, dann wird man eben auch Fan von Defensivplänen. Wo Streich da. Also genau, ich glaube, man kann vielleicht sehen, dass sich das jetzt langsam, aber sicher verändern wird. Ich würde mal sagen, bis dahin ist Streich vor allem ein Defensivtrainer auch. Also all die Jahre jetzt irgendwie, die wir bisher besprochen haben, ist es schon der große Fokus. Und ich glaube, langsam, aber sicher ändert sich das. Wollen wir weiterspringen? 1920, genau. Und zwar, das wird jetzt auch nochmal spannend, weil das sind halt die Corona-Spiele ab März. Also auch vielleicht Erinnerungen, die nicht ganz so schön sind. Hoffenheim fand ich interessant eigentlich. Die wechseln den Trainer Noch und Nöche, Schreuder, Rab Kaltenbach, aber werden Sechste. Also so schlecht war es wohl gar nicht. Und hier fängt Härte auch an, zum Big City Club zu werden. Man versucht alles anders zu machen. Sich nicht mehr auf die Basics zu verlassen, sondern höher weiter hinaus zu wollen. Und da werden sie aber auch noch Zehnte. Also es ging ganz gut. Hose ist bei Gladbach, Nagelsmann bei Leipzig. Und Bayern bekommt vor allem das erste Mal wieder so eine interessante Phase, nämlich mit Flick. Also das war ja spielerisch dann doch durchaus schön anzusehen. Dieses krass offensive, was Bayern da gemacht hat, weil vorher war das ja lange irgendwie nicht so richtig nicht so richtig interessant. Platz 5, 6, 7 ist vielleicht nicht uninteressant, weil das sind Leverkusen-Hoffner im Wolfsburg. Also da hatte man auch das Gefühl, eben das Geld macht es dann halt doch. Also die Teams mit den mit den besseren Kader können in dieser Corona-Zeit sich auch vorne absetzen. Genau, Freiburg. Wo ist Freiburg gelandet?
Ich würde jetzt vielleicht noch, darf ich kurz eine Bundesliga-Frage an Max stellen. Ist das endgültig die Zeit, wo gefühlt die Hälfte der Trainer eine RB-Vergangenheit haben? Wahrscheinlich, ne?
Das müsste sein, ohne dass ich da jetzt genau drauf geguckt habe. Aber aber dadurch, dass es auch diese Corona-Saison war, auch die erste Saison von Union in der ersten Liga, war das ja sowieso so eine ganz, ganz seltsame Spielzeit. Mit dieser Unterbrechung, mit den Geisterspielen. Dann gab es manche Teams, die da sehr gut mit umgehen konnten, andere viel, viel schlechter. Also deswegen, also ja, es müsste so sein. Da müsste ich jetzt nochmal nachgucken. Es war auch jetzt nicht unbedingt der schönste Fußball, den man da gesehen hat, aber es war insgesamt auch einfach eine ganz, ganz seltsame Spielzeit, die ja dann auch die Bundesliga vor allen anderen Saisons beendet hat. Und es war ja auch, also das war ja dann Bremen springt am letzten Spieltag noch in die Relegation und spielt dann, war das dann die Heidenheim-Relegation?
Ja, mit den Krabfangen.
Genau, wo dann die Partnerinnen und Frauen und Freundinnen und Freunde der Spieler noch in einem Akt der Rebellion aus dem VIP-Raum in Stadion sind und sofort wieder zurückgeschickt wurden von den Securitys, weil es dürfen ja keine Menschen in den Innenraum eines Stadions. Also deswegen, für mich läuft diese Saison echt unter so einem Sternchen, auch wenn ich gerade sehe, dass es die 100-Tore-Saison von Bayern war. Aber stimmt da Thomas Müller sie noch so angetrieben am letzten Spieltag, dass sie noch das 100. der Tor machen. Aber es war in allen Belangen schlimm.
Ich frische vielleicht kurz auf, was in Freiburg passiert ist. Das müsste auch die Lewandowski 41er-Saison gewesen sein, weil das war auch in Freiburg, wo Gerd Müller das Rekord geknackt hat. Und dann vor dem Lernstadium das T-Shirt. Wo sie das unterbrochen haben, um ehrlich zu werden.
Ah, stimmt. Und bei Freiburg ging es um Europa.
Genau, und hat dann ausgeglichen durch Günther.
Aber das hat ja gute Tradition. Wir sind über die Saison damals hin drüber gegangen, ohne es zu erwähnen. Man wüsste noch, als Anastasia in der Halbzeit gesungen hat am 34. Spieltag. Und Aljen Robben, die dann selbst vom Rasen schieben wollte. Da ging es nämlich für Freiburg auch noch um Europa.
Es gibt Erinnerungen, die ich gerne verdrängen mag. Genau, kurz Kontext Freiburg. Es gibt drei wichtige Transfers in dem Sommer. Kvon, Jeung und vielleicht am spannendsten Johnny Schmid, der nämlich dafür sorgt, dass man das erste Mal für das 343 in den Wingback hat, für die rechte Seite, der den Namen auch verdient hat. Weil damals ist es Kübler noch nicht. Da wird es dann im Laufe der Zeit. Aber Schmid war damals ein deutlicher Gewinn für den Kader. Deswegen spielt man dann auch sehr viel 343 mit Schmid und Günther auf den Außen. Mit damals schon sehr vielen guten Innenverteidigern im Kader. Ein wichtiges Element da ist Robin Koch, ein zentraler Innenverteidiger, der auch immer wieder in sechster Raum kippt und der sehr viele Verlagerungen spielt. Sehr viel diagonal spielt auf die Außen, sowohl rechts als auch links. Und ich weiß noch, es war damals eine große Diskussion, weil Lukas Waldschmidt war 18, 19, sehr dominant von Anfang an. Und in der Saison ist er dann sehr dominant als Joker. Er übernimmt so ein bisschen die mit Petersen zusammen. Die Rolle von der Bank ist er oft nur zweiter Starter hinter. Ich weiß gar nicht, wer dann neben Höler gespielt hat. Ist auch egal. Man spielt lange um Europa mit, man schafft es aber nicht ganz. Und das Spannende, Micha hat sie auch aufgeschrieben, es streicht dann tatsächlich in der Corona-Zeit, weil man da erst echt so richtig merkt, wenn man ihn hört am Spielfeldrand, dass der Jugendtrainer nie so richtig raus ist aus ihm.
Das wäre vielleicht auch genau jetzt mal eine Frage. Ich weiß nicht mehr, ob ihr das vor allem gut im Kopf habt, aber es gibt halt Trainer, die, also nochmal die Frage, wie ordnet man Streich so insgesamt ein? Es gibt halt Trainer, die jede Situation coachen. Als Freiburg-Fans die Testspiele gucken, wussten wir das vorher auch schon, dass Streich eigentlich jede Situation so durchcoacht, aber bei Corona hat man es halt so richtig gehört. Und es gibt Trainer, die das halt einfach nicht machen. Die stehen so im Prinzip an der Seite und wollen erstens vielleicht, dass die Spiele sich gegenseitig coachen, aber machen das halt irgendwie selber auch nicht. Das fand ich eigentlich noch mal, ich fand es halt eine interessante Detailbeobachtung. Und da wäre jetzt wirklich an meiner Frage, ist das... Max, wie siehst du das? Also denkst du, das ist ein Qualitätsmerkmal oder ist es halt einfach, also sind Trainer halt einfach unterschiedlich und wenn es funktioniert, ist es eh egal. Also dieses Mikrocoaching.
Ich glaube, es gibt halt Spielertypen, also man spricht hier immer so von vier psychologischen Profilen, die wir alle Menschen haben und ohne da ins Detail zu gehen, ich glaube, da gibt es halt dann einfach Profile von Spielern. Wo das gut passt und die das auch brauchen. Und es gibt Spieler, die drehen da durch und wechseln dann weg. Max Kruse würde ich zum Beispiel jetzt als jemanden einschätzen, ohne ihn persönlich zu kennen. Das ist jetzt natürlich nur eine Annahme, aber ich glaube, den nervt das. Vielleicht schaltet er auf Durchzug und es ist ihm egal. Aber könnte man zumindest vorstellen, dass es keine positive Verstärkung ist, bei jeder Aktion gesagt zu bekommen, wo jetzt der freie Mann ist, die man als nächstes anspielt. Und in der Phase hatte Freiburg definitiv schon einen Kader zusammen, weil das zeigen dann die Folgejahre, also das können wir jetzt im Nachhinein auch besser bewerten, bei dem es eben viele Spieler gab, die, glaube ich, damit sehr gut umgehen konnten und die auch das gebraucht haben. Und gleichzeitig war das Interessante, das ist jetzt ein kleiner Schlenker weg vom Sportlichen, aber in der Phase ist es, glaube ich, vor allem so, dass Christian Streich auch neben dem Platz so eine wichtige Rolle spielt. Man hört in viel Coaching, aber wir erinnern uns Corona-Unterbrechung, die damals sich im Wahlkampf befindlichen Armin Laschet und Markus Söder, die sich irgendwie darum streiten, wer jetzt Kanzlerkandidat werden, können verkünden beim Springer-Konzern, dass die Bundesliga weitergehen darf. Und kurz danach wird etwas von der großen Demut erzählt des Fußballs. Aber gleichzeitig setzt sich Christian Seifert damals hin und sagt, also wenn wir jetzt nicht weiterspielen können, sieben bis zwölf Vereine gehen einfach direkt ins Wind. Wir haben einfach gar kein Geld, wir müssen jetzt weiterspielen. Es gibt keine andere Möglichkeit, während eben Kitas, Spielplätze und so weiter geschlossen werden. Und Christian Streich war damals eine ganz wichtige Stimme, weil Christian Streich einer von wenigen im Fußballbetrieb war, der glaubhaft darauf hinweisen konnte, dass man jetzt aber wirklich mal drüber nachdenken muss, welche Rolle der Fußball spielt und dass man da eben die richtige Verhältnismäßigkeit sehen muss. Und ich weiß nicht, ob das jetzt so eine Überinterpretation meinerseits ist, aber ich glaube, mich zu erinnern, dass damals auch ganz viele Aussagen von ihm geteilt wurden und dass er dann fast eigentlich schon reflexartig von der Badischen Zeitung und anderen Medien vor Ort nach allen möglichen Themen gefragt wurde, die gar nichts mit dem Fußball zu tun hatten. Und deswegen wollte ich das hier noch kurz mit einfließen lassen, weil ich glaube, da ist die 1920er-Saison eine ganz wichtige für diesen Aspekt.
Wenn ihr da mehr zuhören wollt, in der großen Streich-Abschiedsfolge, die es vom Spodcast geben wird, wird es zu genau dem Thema Streich als Medienperson einen Teil mit krassen Schröter-Lorens geben.
Ja, es ist eine komische Saison. Ich habe da auch irgendwie nicht mehr ganz so viele Erinnerungen dran tatsächlich, aber ich glaube auch, weil es bei Corona halt so viele andere Sachen im Kopf gab. Was schon vielleicht noch, also ich habe es ja, ich glaube, es ist so ein Jugendtrainer-Ding, dass man jede Sache coacht und Nagelsmann gehört ja auch irgendwie zu einem. Also da finde ich es interessant, dass das ist ja ein Trainer, der wirklich auch andere Teams trainiert hat und ich kann mir auch vorstellen, dass dort dann einige besonders nervt. Ich glaube, Guardiola ist ja wahrscheinlich auch nicht so weit weg. Ich finde es ein bisschen schade, dass man, ich habe mir das eigentlich gar nicht angeschaut, wie der während Corona so gecoacht hat, aber ich meine, der sagt ja auch sehr, sehr viel an und plant sehr, sehr viel vor. Also da hätten wir Streis sogar in einer Riege drin, die so ein bisschen auch höhere Teams gecoacht haben. Aber genau, das ist halt, glaube ich, irgendwann diese Entwicklung, dass halt viele Jugend-Coaches nach oben kommen.
Aber war das nicht auch die Saison, in der man gemerkt hat, wie wichtig Christian Günther ist? Weil man eben auch gemerkt, also weil man die Kommunikation gehört hat und dann wurde eben erstmal deutlich, also das Moderhut bei BVB die ganze Zeit labert, bei Thomas Müller hat es einen jetzt wirklich nicht überrascht, dass er viel sagt. Aber war das nicht auch, dass man bei dem SC Freiburg gesagt hat, ach krass, wie viel auch Christian Günther sagt?
Und dass man da endgültig gemerkt hat, dass Nicolas Hüffler jedes Mal das Pressing-Signal gibt auf dem Feld. Stimmt.
Ja, krass Saison. Kommt, wir gehen gleich weiter einfach zur Corona-Saison. Das ist jetzt die echte Corona-Saison, wo es von Anfang an mit ein paar Zuschauern losgeht. Ich glaube, das sind diese Zeiten mit 500 Zuschauern oder so. Und dann ist aber schnell wieder ganz vorbei. Schalke geht richtig baden. Das ist so, ja, das ist echt ein bisschen traurig diese Saison. Ich glaube, am Ende sind es 16 Punkte oder sowas. Also historisch schlecht. Hütte Eintracht finde ich weiterhin ganz interessant. Sind werden fünfte. Und es ist die Zeit auch, in der beim Spodcast unser normaler Moderator Alex Glasner's Wolfsburg so toll findet, die immerhin, muss man schon sagen, körperlich ein sehr interessantes und sehr stabiles Zentrum bilden. Ja, das hat dann schon was Nagelsmann kassiert, die wenigsten Gegentore der Liga. Und jetzt fängt die Unionzeit an. Kruse ist bei Union und Nico Schlotterbeck ist auch bei Union. Und die werden siebte am letzten Spieltag.
Ja, man kriegt Abgänge im Sommer. Und das erste Mal löst das nicht so richtig Panik aus, weil Koch, Schwolo und Waldschmidt gehen. Man ist aber inzwischen so stabil finanziell auch aufgestellt. Man plant auch schon den Umzug ins neue Stadion und so. Das ist emotional ein großes Thema damals, dass man nicht weiß, ob das jemals unter Zuschauern stattfindet und so. In dem Sommer kommen aber dann Flecken ersetzt Schwolo. Das war so im Verein so geplant, dass es passieren wird. Und Santa Maria und Demirovic ersetzen Koch und Waldschmidt plus Kevin Schlotterbeck kommt von dessen Neier von Union zurück, weil Union und Schlotterbecks, das hat ganz gut funktioniert für Freiburg. Und man spielt wieder relativ viel Dreierkette. Und man muss aber sagen, die große Geschichte rund um diese Saison ist, dass bis auf sieben richtig, richtig tolle Wochen die Einbindung von Baptis Santa Maria nicht so funktioniert, wie man es gerne hätte. Dafür macht Demirovic sehr viel Spaß in seiner ersten Saison in Freiburg.
Ja, ich weiß nicht, einfach nochmal diese Corona-Zeit, weil ich glaube, das hat ja dann doch irgendwie eine große Auswirkung, dass da keine Zuschauer da sind und so. Und zwar war schon eine besondere Zeit. Deswegen, Max, ich weiß nicht, hast du Erinnerungen insgesamt an diese Saison? Was passiert da? Welche Teams können Corona nutzen? Also, oder was heißt nutzen? Aber welche Teams kommen da gut durch? Welche Teams kommen da nicht gut durch? Kann man das klustern? Und wie passt Freiburg da rein?
Kann man das klustern? Ich glaube, dass das eine Saison war, in der zum einen Teams Probleme hatten, die von ihrem Publikum abhängig sind. Das, meine ich, sieht man auch am Ende in der Tabelle. Unter anderem auch an Schalke. Also, es gibt ja viele Schalke-Fans. Und wir erinnern uns, sie waren damals kurz davor, den Tasmanier-Rekord zu brechen. Wisst ihr noch, als Tasmanier-Fans beim letzten Spiel waren und für Schalke waren, damit dieser Rekord bleiben darf. Also, sie waren natürlich nur vor dem Stadion. Im Stadion durften sie, glaube ich, damals noch nicht. Aber auch Dortmund hatte so Phasen, wo... Also, die haben zehn Niederlagen, Dortmund, in dieser Saison. Und ich glaube, mich zu erinnern, dass das damals auch ein Thema war. Und solche Teams hatten Probleme. Ausnahme dann Union, wobei Union generell in der ganzen Corona-Zeit ja ein Sonderfall war mit dem Stehplatzversuchen und manchen Aussagen, die jetzt auch nicht jedem gefallen haben da draußen. Also, sehr viel aufgeregte Diskussionen. Und wenn ich mich richtig erinnere, war Freiburg doch einfach eines der Teams zusammen mit Stuttgart, wo es überraschend war, weil die aufgestiegen sind, und mit Hoffenheim, wo es seitdem nie wieder anders werden sollte, das einfach so durchgecruist ist durch diese Saison. Tordifferenz 52 zu 52. Und ich glaube, so war doch auch die ganze Saison. Man hatte nie Angst um Freiburg, man wusste aber auch nie, was richtig Krasses passieren wird. Und deswegen war dann dieses Santa-Maria-Thema, was an jedem anderen Standort ein Riesending gewesen wäre, dass der Rekord-Transfer dieses Sommers dann gar keine Rolle mehr spielt, Heimweg kriegt und wieder geht. Das war im Grunde gar kein Thema. Und man hat ja sogar noch Geld für ihn bekommen. Also in der Phase hat ja auch alles funktioniert für Freiburg.
Ja, also ich würde da eigentlich auch mitgehen, dass man schon sehr reduziert auf diese spielerische und auf die Spielanlage, die es dann halt irgendwie so gab in dieser Saison. Und dass Teams, die da halbwegs solide aufgestellt waren, halt irgendwie das unemotional ganz gut über die Bühne gewuppt haben. Und das ist schon interessant, dass Freiburg eben zu dem Zeitpunkt, ich weiß nicht, wie das gewesen wäre, 13, 14 oder so, ob Freiburg da nicht mehr Probleme gehabt hätte. Aber hier hat Freiburg dann irgendwie schon so ein Grundniveau, in dem sie einfach so eine Saison dann solide klinisch zu Ende bekommen irgendwie.
Ich glaube, es ist auch die erste Saison, da hat man viel selber für getan, aber es ist halt auch die erste Saison, wo man nicht mehr eine Überperformance von Streich taktisch braucht, wenn man das jetzt auf den Trainer zurückführt, um die Klasse zu halten, sondern der Kader hat relativ viel individuelle Klasse in sich. Also Höfler ist zu dem Zeitpunkt einer der besten Sechser der Liga. Die Innenverteidigung mit Kevin Stotterberg, Heinz und Linard braucht ein bisschen, um sich zu finden, weil man vergisst ein bisschen, dass der Anfang der Saison bis zu einem Main-Spiel, wo man in der Halbzeit alles taktisch umstellt und dann danach zu den Basics zurückgeht, das Thema hatten wir schon, und dann beginnt zu gewinnen und dann diese Phase vor dem Winter kommt, wieder mit 4-4-4-2 und eben Santa Marias bester Phase, wo man, glaube ich, sechs Spieler in Folge gewinnt, damals mit persönlichem Vereinsrekord. Und dann gibt es die Santa Maria Verletzung und dann das schlechte Teil seiner Saison. Ich glaube, deswegen ist es auch während der Saison kein Thema, weil man eigentlich damals noch denkt, okay, zur neuen Saison greift er dann voll an. Vielleicht ist es deswegen, also ja, es ist auch, weil es Freiburg ist, offensichtlich.
Und war es nicht auch damals so, da war doch das Stadion im Fertigwerden und es hätte eigentlich eingeweiht werden sollen zur Rückrunde oder so. Und dann hat man aber schon gesehen, es wird länger dauern. Und ich glaube, das war damals noch so ein großes Thema. Aber das Gefühl war eben, jetzt ist man vom nächsten Schritt. Also während ich vorhin diesen Piszczty-Kommentar deswegen vorgelesen habe, um zu zeigen, wie schlecht damals die Stimmung war und wie schlecht auch die Prognosen waren von außen. Freiburg ist so arm, das Nachwuchskonzept haben alle anderen kopiert und so weiter und so fort. Was jetzt so, dass man sich gedacht hat, Mensch, man ist super gut durch dieses Song gekommen und wie geil wird das erst, wenn man ein neues Stadion hat. Auch wenn natürlich für alle Freiburg-Fans der Abschiedsschmerz extrem groß war, inklusive mir. Ich konnte nicht beim letzten Spiel im Dreisam-Stadion sein. Das war sehr schade. Aber da hat man eigentlich immer in die nächste Saison geguckt.
Ja, kann man mit Sicherheit so sagen. Vielleicht muss die Saison aber dann tatsächlich dafür herhalten. Ich habe es gerade Nicolas Höfler angesprochen, weil man den taktischen Trainer Streich nicht so ganz ohne die Person Nicolas Höfler erzählen kann. Ab dem Jahr 2017, 2018 sowas. Und Santa Maria war ja eigentlich so der Versuch, diese Höflerrolle langfristig auszufüllen. Und man hat ihn dann viel als Achter gespielt und so. Und er hat sich nie so richtig wohlgefühlt, weil in den Räumen, in denen er in Frankreich so stark war, da ist Höfler unglaublich dominant gewesen. Und Streich hat auch nicht so richtig einen Weg daraus gefunden, um beide miteinander co-existieren zu lassen, weil er diese Höflerrolle nicht ausgeben wollte, die er da hatte im System. Also, Micha, wir loben jede Woche Nikolas Höfler immer noch. Ich finde auch, er könnte jede Woche im Rasenfunk der Ansagen Hero sein.
Das stimmt, das stimmt. Er hatte ja auch häufig mal, es gab da ein paar Saisons, wo er am Anfang so zwei, drei große Probleme hatte. Ja, aber es ist gut, dass du Höfler nochmal ansprichst. Es ist ja jetzt auch interessant, dass sich Streich da rausgemogelt hat. Er wird Höfler nicht mehr ersetzen müssen. Das wäre nämlich noch eine große Frage gewesen. Ich glaube, ich würde das wahrscheinlich schon vergleichen mit damals, als bei Augsburg Daniel Bayer gegangen ist. Also so in etwa. Ähnlich dominant ist Höfler. Ja, also das stimmt absolut. Und ich dachte auch, dass Santa Maria alleiniger Sechser werden könnte. Und Höfler vielleicht vorne in Achterrollen reinkommt und so. Und hat halt überhaupt nicht funktioniert. Da würde ich ja auch gerne mal also Streich fragen, wie, ob das damals, also ob das damals wirklich so geplant war und dann hat es nicht so funktioniert. Oder ob das Santa Maria von vorneherein als Achter geplant hat und Höfler die tiefe Rolle behalten sollte. Sehr gute Frage. Ja, noch was zu der Saison. Ist das die Aufstiegssaison eigentlich von zweiten Team? Ich glaube schon.
Ja, die Steigen wären.
Also das ist halt, weil das ist auch interessant. Ich glaube, das hat man von außen nicht so gesehen. Aber ich erinnere mich, dass ich halt sehr, sehr gerne dieses Spiele gesehen habe mit Cildilia und Ezequim. Also als Dreierverteidiger. Pieringer, Schade, Weißhaupt, Luca Herrmann. Es ist halt eine unfassbare Mannschaft, wo jetzt alle eigentlich schon irgendwie im Profifußball gelandet sind, die dort dann zusammen waren und es geschafft hatten, die dritte Liga aufzusteigen. Und da hat man schon gesehen, okay, da kommt jetzt, da kommt was nach. Und das wird mal interessant sein, wie der Jugend- oder Ex-Jugendtrainer Streich die integrieren kann. Das wird ein Thema dann der nächsten Saisons.
Und ein Aspekt, der mir jetzt gerade noch eingefallen ist. Damals hat sich auch das Bild vom SC Freiburg aus wirtschaftlicher Position in der Liga geändert. Und zwar, wir erinnern uns, Freiburg wurde noch vor ein paar Saisons noch als finanzschwacher Verein eingeschätzt. Freiburg war einer mit Augsburg und noch ein paar anderen. Der Vereine, die extrem gut durch Corona durchgekommen sind. Und was damals fast schon ein Wunder war, war, dass man diese Stadion fertig bauen konnte und dafür ja keine Schulden aufgenommen hat. Also ich habe hier nämlich im Sendungsdokument für die nächste Saison, und da beziehe ich ja quasi mich immer auf die jüngst veröffentlichen Zahlen, habe ich geschrieben, finanziell ist der SC einfach nur noch krass. Trotz Corona wieder ein solides Ergebnis und das Stadion gebaut ohne Schulden. Das ist schon Wahnsinn. Und ich glaube, zusammen mit dieser sportlich sehr neutralen, aber im positiven Sinne Saison und eben dem neuen Stadion hat sich da was verschoben, dass man dann jetzt gesehen hat und Santa Maria ist ihnen nicht auf die Füße gefallen. Man hat das Gefühl gehabt, jetzt nimmt Freiburg eine nächste Stufe und das wird sich ja dann später auch in den ersten Transfers zeigen, die man früher bestimmt nicht gemacht hätte.
Also ich hätte noch was, aber das ist ein größerer Punkt, den ich gerne ganz am Ende besprechen würde, wenn wir über die aktuelle sprechen. Über die Probleme der aktuellen.
Gut, dann nimm uns gerne mit in die Saison 21, 22. Was denn da bei der Bundesliga passiert?
Wir haben sehr erfolgreiche Pressing-Teams. Union wird fünfter, Baumgart's Köln siebter, Svensons Mainz achter. Und vor allen Dingen haben wir auch so ein bisschen die Saison von sehr erfolgreichen 5-3-2-Teams in 21, 22. In der Spitze hat man Nagelsmann, der bei Bayern ganz gut funktioniert. Rose bei Dortmund so halber. Tedesco bei RB eher nicht. Wenn auch leider in einem Spiel dann doch. Und Seohane bei Leverkusen recht gut. Arminia und Fürth sind oben, sind aber zu schwach. Und deswegen retten sich Hertha und Stuttgart nicht wegen eigener Stärke, sondern wegen der Schwäche der anderen. Aber eigentlich ist es taktisch noch eine relativ unspannende Liga in dem Jahr. Also das 5-3-2 ist schon ein sehr prägendes Element, aber es ist jetzt nichts, was mich begeistern kann. Deswegen möchte ich da nicht so lange drüber sprechen.
Mich hat es am Anfang begeistert. Ich mag defensiv Pläne und also was Baumgart mit Köln am Anfang gemacht hat. Ich fand es schon sehr stark. Genau. SC Freiburg. Also Santa Maria geht wieder und es kommt Eggestein und vor allem kommt Nico Schlotterbeck zurück. Und jetzt fängt es eben an, dass diese Jugendspieler oben integriert werden. Also es kommen Cildilia, Schade, Weißhaupt. Keitel war glaube ich vorher schon da ein bisschen, aber der kommt dann auch einfach hoch und alle bekommen ihre Spielzeiten. Also die werden integriert nicht so komplett, sondern eher alle, dass sie so langsam reinkommen, aber sie werden alle nach und nach integriert und sind irgendwie Teil vom Freiburger Team. Wesentlicher Bestandteil sind aber Nico Schlotterbeck und Linhardt, die einfach also ein absolut krasses Innenverteidigerduo bilden, gemeinsam mit Flecken hinten dran. Und deswegen spielt Freiburg auch sehr, sehr viel Viererkette. Sie haben hin und wieder Dreierkette gespielt. Ich erinnere mich da auch noch dran, dass da der Nico Schlotterbeck aber diese Weiträumigkeit nicht so ausbilden konnte. Deswegen sind mir die Viererkettenauftritte schon deutlich besser in Erinnerung gegangen. Und ich habe auch das Gefühl, dass hier merkt man jetzt mehr und mehr, Streich kann auf Dinge aufbauen, die jetzt irgendwie schon lange ein Team vermittelt hat, das irgendwie schon lange auch zusammen spielt. Ich meine, wir haben eigentlich den Kader, sind wir als Ganz so richtig durchgegangen. Aber wir haben ja noch zig Spieler, die wir von der Aufstiegssaison da haben, mit Höfler, Günther, Petersen ist da ja auch noch dabei und so. Höhler ist ganz lange dabei und so weiter und so fort. Kübler nicht zu vergessen. Grifo kippt häufiger raus. Das ist auch noch eine Sache, dass er sich immer tiefer fallen lässt und immer mehr in den Spielaufbau einbringen lässt. Und da ist auch so dieses Grifo-Günther-Ding immer stärker, dass die so richtig gut zusammen harmonieren. Und ich glaube, was da jetzt so richtig stark wird, ist, dass dieser kollektive Ansatz von den Streichern am Anfang hatte, der ist langsam passé. Also Freiburg ist nicht mehr das Team, das sich vor allem dadurch definiert, dass alle im Kollektiv genau das Richtige machen, sondern es geht immer mehr darum, wie man einzelne Spiele in gute Situationen bringen kann. Eben mit Grifo mit dem Ball, Nico Schlotterbeck gegen den Ball. Und ja, also Streich passt sich eben daran an, dass er einen besseren Kader zur Verfügung hat. Das ist schon eine sehr, sehr gute Leistung, würde ich mal sagen. Jo, DFB Pokalfinale. Das ist halt ein großes Highlight, das man hat. DFB Pokalfinale und Europa League. Hier kommen wir zum Höhenflug des SC Freiburg. Und ja, ich glaube, ich meine, da sehen es dann langsam auch alle. Max, du hast vorhin gesagt, vorher war der Blick von außen so, dass man, wenn man viel Freiburg gesehen hat, konnte man sehen, dass Streich interessante Pressingpläne hat. Jetzt konnten alle sehen, dass Streich irgendwie da ein Team zusammenbastelt, das guten Fußball spielen kann auch.
Ja, wobei ich möchte eine Einschränkung dazu machen. Ich glaube, dass mit dem guten Fußball war damals auch schon noch ein bisschen eher der Blick der Freiburger Fans auf den SC, weil das ist jetzt auch die Phase. Jetzt sind wir in der Phase, in der Freiburg echte Standardmonster sind und in der mit Union und Freiburg zwei sehr, sehr gute Teams nach Standards letztlich um die Champions League spielen. Man liegt am Ende in der Tabelle drei Punkte hinter Raba Leipzig. Und das war der Hauptdiskussionspunkt der letzten Spieltage. Oh Gott, wollen wir, dass Union oder Freiburg in der Champions League spielt? Wieder für Deutschland sind wir wieder bei dem alten Narrativ. Also ja, es gab schon den besseren Fußball. Und da haben wir auch drüber gesprochen. Und gerade das Polyvalente sowohl der Spieler im Kader als auch in der taktischen Formation, das war da mit am besten zu sehen in dieser Saison. Aber die Tore hat man eben oft immer noch. Also 19 Tore hat man nach Standards gemacht von 58. Dazu noch fünf nach Strafstößen. Damit war man bestes Team in der Liga. Und ich weiß noch, dass das quasi so sehr der Außenblick war auf Freiburg. Die machen halt immer das 1 zu 0 über den Standard und dann kriegen sie es halt nach Hause.
Wunderbar, Max, dass du die Perspektive mit reinbringst. Das ist natürlich, wenn man es als Freiburg-Fan mit den Jahren davor vergleicht, denkt man sich, Mann, das war doch so schöner Fußball, der da gespielt wurde. Und weil es hatte ja auch dann mehr mit Spielaufbau und so weiter zu tun. Also was da dann mit Nico Schlotterbeck und Lienhardt passiert ist als früher. Also es war nicht nur ein langer Ball. Ja, und auch vorne konnte man dann ja irgendwie ein bisschen mehr sehen als davor. Gerade, ich meine, Grifo, das muss man vielleicht auch nochmal im Nachhinein sagen, dass der damals irgendwie zurückkam und dann auch klar wurde, Freiburg geht jetzt diese Entwicklung, dass sie so einen Spieler halten kann. Das hat schon einiges mit der Spielkultur gemacht.
Und dann gab es halt die Pokalsaison.
Müssen wir das jetzt wirklich besprechen.
Patrick, du hast es damals auch schon besprochen im Rasenfunktorial.
Genau, richtig. Das ist richtig. Ja, also die Pokalsaison überstrahlt glaube ich für 2021, 2022 auch vieles, was in der Saison spielerisch nicht so toll war, weil man die individuell beste spielerische Leistung in Hoffenheim hatte, die man 4-1 auswärts überrollt hat im Achtelfinale. Man war in Hamburg sehr deutlich überlegen vor allen Dingen, aber individuell gegen Tim Walther, der halt so ins offene Messer gelaufen ist. Welche Überraschung. Ja, also die Pokalsaison war halt aber auch emotional absolut verrückt. Das zehrt heute noch. Es gibt das meinrömisches Reiches, der Demirovic-Schuss in der Verlängerung.
In den der Stadionsprecher die Nachspielzeit reingearbeitet hat.
Stimmt, da haben wir uns vorher gesehen, vor dem Spiel. Ja, ich weiß gar nicht. 21, 22, eigentlich, wenn wir rein beim Taktischen bleiben, haben wir eigentlich alles angesprochen. Vielleicht der beste Nico Stotterbeck, den wir bis jetzt zu dieser Rückrunde gesehen haben in 21, 22, was auch sehr viel mit Philipp Linhardt neben ihm zu tun hatte, weil man da auch einfach so eine gute Balance hatte, die man jetzt auch mit Jinter Linhardt hatte, aus einem sehr aggressiv verteidigenden Innenverteidiger und einem, der einfach unglaublich guter Rennistie tiefer abzusichern mit Philipp Linhardt, der da eigentlich immer noch unter dem Radar fliegt, glaube ich. Die beste Höfler-Saison. Bis dahin ist er immer noch gealtert wie guter Wein. Und dann beginnt es auch ganz langsam, das werden wir erst in 22, 23, das erste Mal so richtig sehen, wenn dann auch Dorn und Schway noch dazukommen, dass man offensiv tatsächlich die Möglichkeit hat, so alle Spielzonen anzuspielen. Weil man war ja sehr lange sehr linkslastig. Das war man noch 21, 22 noch. Aber es begann dann so langsam, dass man Grifo immer häufiger im linken Halbraum hatte oder irgendwo sonst auf dem Feld. Günther hat dann links die Breite gehalten, das sehr hoch geschoben. Rechts hatte man Scholleu. Später, also in der nächsten Saison, hatte man Dorn rechts und Scholleu dann sogar noch im rechten Halbraum und in der Mitte Schway. Das war halt ganz cool, weil man dann wirklich alle fünf Zonen anspielen konnte. Und das hat man 21, 22 auch teilweise schon gesehen, aber es hat halt nicht in Torgefahr gemündet, sondern die Torgefahr ist dann doch durch Standards entstanden. Ich weiß noch, dass ich in der Saison sehr häufig mir gedacht hatte, wie cool es wäre, wenn man das Team hätte im Aufbau und in der Chancen-Erarbeitung mit dem Petersen von vier, fünf Jahren vorher, weil dann, ja, hätte er das nicht mehr alleine tragen müssen.
Aber ja, 58 Tore, also es ist ja nicht, zwei nicht so schlecht mit dem Ball. Aber ihr habt schon gesagt, es sind viele Standards gewesen. Kevin Schade würde ich noch gerne erwähnen. Also auch wieder jemand, der eine Spezialrolle von Streich bekommen hat und wo Streich dann halt auch drüber gesprochen hat. Tempo ist was, also das kann man, wenn man das halt nicht hat, dann fehlt einem eine große Dimension im Spiel. Da hat man auch wieder gemerkt, dass er, der weiß schon auch immer wieder, dass er mit sehr limitierten Mitteln irgendwie gearbeitet hat. Und ich fand es auch interessant, dass wenn er dann irgendwie die Mittel zur Verfügung hatte, große Spiele, dann spiele ich einen langen Ball, schnelle Spiele, dann lasse ich auch hinter die Kette spielen. Und wenn man die halt nicht zur Verfügung hat, dann hat man es halt auch gelassen. Es war immer die Frage, kann Streich irgendwie damit umgehen, wenn er ein bisschen mehr zur Verfügung hat. Da hat er schon immer angedeutet, es geht. Also er weiß schon, wie er es macht, auch wenn es bei Schade meistens so war, dass er eher gekommen ist, wenn Freiburg in Führung lag und man dann nochmal ein bisschen kontern konnte. Wollen wir weitergehen?
Ja, ich würde vielleicht noch den einen Aspekt, ich verstehe schon, Patrick, dass du das nicht nochmal ausführlicher ansprechen willst, aber das Pokalfinale, wo man, was hat man letztlich jetzt auch in der Rückschau in diesem Finale gesehen, neben dem, dass es natürlich einen Fans sehr wehgetan hat, man hat gesehen, dass die Überzahl Freiburg total rausgebracht hat. Und das finde ich ist schon jetzt gerade in der Rückschau, weil wir wissen, wie sich Freiburg weiterentwickelt hat, etwas, was damals noch nicht da war und bemerkenswert ist, eben die fehlende Abgezocktheit. Man hatte einen super guten Plan gegen zehn Feldspieler und als man gegen neun Feldspieler dann mehr den Ball hatte und irgendwie auch das Gefühl hatte, man müsse jetzt mehr tun, wurde es fahrig und Streich hat es dann auch nicht geschafft, von außen richtig einzuwirken. Und ich würde, und das ist vielleicht dann die Brücke, sagen, das hat man dann unter anderem auch durch gute Neuzugänge für die neue Saison deutlich verbessert.
Voll und ganz, ja, genau, schöne Brücke. Aber noch einen, also genau, einen Schritt zurück. Wir fangen wieder mit dem Kontext der Bundesliga an.
Ja, wir haben jetzt in den letzten Jahren gar nicht so viel über die Bundesliga gesprochen, weil vielleicht müsste man das auch 22, 23 nochmal dazu sagen. In der Bundesliga tut sich taktisch nicht so viel. Das ist jetzt 23, 24 das erste Mal. Aber ich war ja auch schon jetzt sehr lange Rasenfunk. Und also ihr sprecht schon sehr häufig über das Gleiche, oder ihr habt sehr häufig über das Gleiche gesprochen, über diese Umschalt-Liga, in der niemand so richtig gerne den Ball haben möchte und so. Und das ändert sich eigentlich über sieben, acht Jahre nicht wirklich.
Für mich ist alles, was wir jetzt besprechen, eine Saison.
Genau. Und dann ist auch eben 22, 23. Es gibt einfach keine positiven Geschichten in der Liga, bis auf Freiburg und Union. Schalke steigt wieder ab, Bayern entlässt Nagelsmann, wird unter Tuchel irgendwie Meister, Terzic wird Fastmeister. Richtig glücklich ist niemand. Leipzig ist nicht richtig glücklich mit Rose, wobei das gegen Ende der Saison ein bisschen besser wird für die. Stuttgart rettet sich mit Sebastian Hoeneß nach vier Trainern. Hertha geht runter und Köln hält noch mal solide die Klasse unter Baumgart. Und eben nur Freiburg und Union bestätigen den Erfolg. Denn auch bei Mainz war letztes Jahr schon ein bisschen zu sehen unter Borus Frenzon, dass diese ganz krasse Saison wie 21, 22 nicht ganz zu halten ist dort.
Ja, und bei Freiburg nähern, also oder ich würde sagen, das ist jetzt Peak, was wir da gesehen haben. Vielleicht kann man es halt noch vergleichen mit der Kruse Saison und so, die auch sehr, sehr stark war. Aber ja, okay, beginnen wir erst mal damit, dass es ist dieses Mal dann doch ein interessanter Umbruch. Es gehen nämlich schon einige Spieler vor dieser Saison. Es gehen Schade. Nico Schlotterbeck, also der beste Spieler geht dann, eigentlich der Klassiker. Haberer und Demirovic gehen auch. Aber es kommen Ginter, Trey, Gregoritsch und Doan. Und da kann man dann eben sehen, dass das, was du auch gesagt hast, Max, mit dem, dass Freiburg halt finanziell ganz gut dasteht. Jetzt kann man halt Abgänge wirklich einfach eins zu eins ersetzen, obwohl das mit Ginter auch eine spezielle Story ist. Ich weiß nicht, ob man Spiele von dem Format bekommen hätte, wenn der halt nicht irgendwie diese Freiburger Vergangenheit gehabt hätte. Das hat schon wahrscheinlich auch damit zu tun gehabt.
Ja, aber Doan war, glaube ich, doch der Transfer, an dem man das sehen konnte. Weil früher hätte man Doan nur von Bielefeld kaufen können. Später war es eigentlich zu spät. Und jetzt hat man ihn von PSW geholt für 8,5 Millionen. Also ich weiß noch, dass das der Transfer war, wo man so richtig aufgehört hat, weil Doan auch in der Abstiegssaison von Bielefeld einer oder eigentlich der beste Bielefelder war. Und weil man ja gesehen hat, ach Moment, das ist ja ein ganz anderer Spielertyp. Die wollen auch jetzt nicht etwa mit Ball auch was machen.
Genau. Also wunderbar. Obwohl ich auch am Anfang gesagt habe, boah, Doan, mal sehen, was der so gegen den Ball bringt. Und hatte das gar nicht auf dem Schirm, was für eine Maschine der ist. Und wie der sich in Zweikämpfe reinwuselt, das war, ja genau, es ist halt wirklich best of both worlds, dieser Let's Doan aktuell halt auch. Genau, also es ist historisch die beste Hinserie. Sie geht nur 15 Spiele lang, wegen der Winter WM. Aber Freiburg spielt 8 von 15 Spielen zu 0 und kommt ungeschlagen durch die Europa League. Also das war dann, ich weiß auch noch, ich meine, wir haben da ein Podcast gemacht und es waren halt vollkommen ungläubig die ganze Zeit. Was passiert hier auch? Und ich habe der ganzen Sache irgendwie auch nur so halb getraut, aber man gewöhnt sich als Fan dann ja doch irgendwie so schnell dran. Also wie so, als ob man so Leverkusen-Fan ist aktuell, dass man glaubt auch, man gewinnt alles. Das ist irgendwie so ganz normal, das ist irgendwie so sehr entspannt. Du nicht, du hast noch die alte Freiburger.
Nee, nee, gar nicht. Ich bin nach dem 2-0 gegen Nord in der Europa League Gruppenphase aus dem Stadion rausgegangen, habe festgestellt, dass ich bei beiden Toren nur so leicht die Faust geballt habe. Also wir haben ein Europa League Heimspiel gewonnen, das war verrückt.
Ja, also die Rückrunde kommt da jetzt nicht so ganz ran. Genau, aber man schafft es halt trotzdem dann irgendwie ziemlich souverän in die Europa League. Und gerade wenn man das halt vergleicht mit der ersten Europa League Saison, was wir dann vorhin gesagt haben, wo man die Europa League eigentlich nur so als Bürde nehmen konnte und in der Liga dann fast abgestiegen ist, war es jetzt halt eine vollkommen andere Saison. Taktisch, formativ, wieder recht flexibel, wieder sehr stark auf die Spiele zugeschnitten. Gibt so Mischformationen, auch mit Dreier- und Viererkette, auch mit Schade als Wingback, aber es ist so wirklich viel um Ginther und Lienhard herum. Die bilden das neue Zentrum von einer sehr, sehr guten Defensive. Und hier finde ich jetzt aber auch, also ich glaube, ich wiederhole mich auch ein bisschen, aber nochmal ausgehend davon, für mich war Streich früher dieser 4-4-2-Trainer und mit sehr klaren Abläufen. Jetzt hat sich das Gefühl, man hat sich über die Jahre so ein Repertoire dran geschafft. Es gibt Aufbau mit zwei Innenverteidiger, mit drei Innenverteidiger, mit vier Innenverteidiger und von, also wirklich von Angriffsequenz oder von Aufbausequenz zur Aufbausequenz passen das, ich würde auch sagen, Spiele selbstständig an. Also wahrscheinlich hat man es schon vorgesprochen, dass man so was gut funktionieren könnte, vielleicht gegen andere Gegner, aber es wird sehr, sehr fluide und es wird auch, finde ich, also schwer für mich, dann irgendwie so klar zu sagen, was war denn das jetzt eigentlich taktisch nach dem Spiel? Und das ist schon irgendwie eine starke Entwicklung. Ich glaube auch, eine, die man insgesamt in der Liga sieht, dass das nicht mehr so, also dass Formationen nicht mehr so ganz klar sind, sondern dass man es eher aufteilen muss in, früher musste man auch schon mit dem Ball und gegen den Ball aufteilen, aber ja, dass man das Spiel eher so sequenzieren muss und dann eher über bestimmte Räume, über bestimmte Muster reden muss und nicht mehr so sagen kann, was macht ein Team über 90 Minuten? Das hat sich dann halt doch alles sehr flexibilisiert. Genau, das wäre eigentlich dann so mein Fazit zu diesem Peak-Streich, dass da eigentlich, dass ich das gar nicht mehr so gut festmachen kann. Was hat Streich da eigentlich so gut gemacht? Es war gut mit dem Ball, es war gut gegen den Ball, aber anders als früher. Es war nämlich gut gegen den Ball, oft auch in der Strafraumverteidigung und gut mit dem Ball, auch wieder im Aufbau, aber mit Flecken am Anfang. Auch immer lange Bälle auf Höhle, also ganz klassische Sache. Da hat sich schon einiges geändert.
Ich glaube, dass die Saison 21, 22 und die Hinrunde 22, 23, wenn man sie von heutigen Zeitpunkt aus anguckt, im Moment nicht so sehr von Personen entschieden wurden, aber so rückblickend es schon sind. Also man sah in 22, 23 in der Hinrunde auch so krass aus, weil man einfach super häufig mit Ginter und Lina zu zweit abgesichert hat und dann neun Leute, ne, acht Leute, hatte, die sich um Chancen-Erarbeitung kümmern konnten. 21, 22 das gleiche mit Schlotterbeck und Lienhardt. Und in der Rückrunde 23 ist es schon passiert, da hat sich Lienhardt in Turin verletzt und dann waren da sechs, sieben Wochen richtig, richtig zäh und jetzt über diese Saison, über die Innenverteidiger-Situation, brauche ich nicht sprechen, da haben Ginter und Lienhardt sechs oder sieben Spiele zusammen gemacht, wo beide gesund waren und dann sieht das Ganze nicht mehr so toll aus. Da können wir gleich nochmal drüber sprechen, da habe ich auch noch ein paar andere Ideen dazu. Aber ich glaube, wenn man die Hinrunde 22, 23 bespricht, darf man das nicht so ganz vergessen, dass man eben auch so ein Selbstverständnis darin hatte, wie man Angriffe abgesichert hat, dass man Angriffe auch super riskant ausführen konnte. Also was, keine Ahnung, Daniel Kofi-Tresa nicht sofort toll aus in der Bundesliga, aber was er halt teilweise im Zehnerraum machen durfte, einfach mal ins Dribbling gehen, im Sechserraum, im gegnerischen, mit zwei Innenverteidigern dahinter, weil Höfler und Eggenstein breit standen. Das hätte man jetzt in der des diesigen Saison nicht gemacht, wenn dahinter Gulde, Kübler und Keitel gestanden wären, da bin ich mir relativ sicher.
Ja, und aber ein bisschen auch nein. Es ist total schlimm, weil ich bin hier immer der Miesmacher. Aber das, was ihr vorhin angedeutet habt, nämlich dass diese Saison im Positiven eine Eigendynamik entwickelt hat und die aber an einzelnen Spielern dann hingen, das hast du ja gerade sehr schön gesagt. Und wir erinnern uns zu dieser Saison gehört ja, dass man gegen Juve spielt und mit ein bisschen mehr Glück irgendwie da mit einem 1-1 aus dem Hinspiel rausgeht und Rückspiel war jetzt auch nicht so schlecht. Und Christian Streich sitzt in der Pressekonferenz und sagt, das ist so toll, dass ich das noch erleben darf. Wir fahren jetzt alle nach Turin. Ich danke einfach nur meinen Jungs, dass sie es gemacht haben, weil er konnte nicht selber gar nicht so genau sagen, woran das jetzt genau lag. Weil in unterschiedlichen Spielen waren es immer wieder unterschiedliche Spieler, die es rausgerissen haben. Und die Defensive hast du ja gerade schon wunderbar rausgearbeitet, war die Basis. Und so ist man ganz lange durch diese Saison durchgekommen. So hat man auch Bayern aus dem DFB-Pokal geworfen und alle dachten, au im Halbfinale revanchieren sie sich an Rabah. Und dann war das ein Spiel, müssen wir jetzt nicht drüber legen. Das war ein ganz, ganz, ich habe ab einem gewissen Spielstand nichts mal von diesem Spiel gesehen. Und das sollte alles sagen. Aber was zu dieser Saison schon auch mit dazu gehört, ist, dass da viele Dinge für den SC Freiburg gefallen sind. Also auch hier habe ich wieder die Community-Power hinter mir aus dem damaligen Royal. Da hat Kev917 zum Beispiel rausgesucht, dass man 16,5 Punkte mehr hatte, als die Expected Points gewesen wären, laut Goal Impact. Wir wollen diese Statistik nicht überbewerten, aber es zeigt, es sind eben schon wirklich manche Ergebnisse für Freiburg gefallen. Man war damals nur auf Platz 14 bei den Toren aus dem Spiel heraus. Also dieses Thema, was sich quasi in der Vor-Saison aufgebaut hat, wo es dann hieß, oh Gott, die vertreten Deutschland in Europa. Wir wissen jetzt, alle liefen ganz wunderbar, bis gegen Juve und so weiter und hätte da auch noch weitergehen können. Das war schon auch wieder hier. Hier war jetzt dann Union wieder bestes Standard-Team. In der Vor-Saison waren sie gar nicht so gut. Und man war eben auch sehr kopfballstark, drittbestes Team bei Kopfballen. Also deswegen, die Freiburger Sicht war diese Zauber-Saison und das war sie auch. Und man hat auch von außen gesehen, Freiburg hat hier eine Entwicklung genommen, weil man in der Europa League so souverän war, weil man jemanden wie Littsdorn verpflichten konnte, weil man einfach so sehr souverän in sehr vielen Spielen war. Aber die Saison war auch deshalb so ein Märchen für Freiburg, weil Dinge wie im Märchen passiert sind. Dass man eben, also wie oft hat da Grifo mit einer Ecke das 1 zu 0 vorbereitet? Ich hab jetzt die Zahlen nicht hier, aber es war sehr, sehr häufig. Und das zeigt halt auch, dass Freiburg, obwohl es eine Entwicklung gemacht hat, sowohl taktisch als auch finanziell, übrigens ist das auch die Saison mit dem Investor. Ja klar, wo Leki dann auf einmal größter Investorenfreund ist. Also eine mehrfach interessante Saison von Freiburg. Also man hat gesehen, sie haben eine Entwicklung gemacht und sie sind jetzt definitiv im oberen Drittel der Tabelle angekommen. Aber in der Saison kannst du sehr gut ablesen. Es muss alles an den richtigen Platz fallen, damit Freiburg dann auch wirklich Platz 5, super souverän, kurz hinter Union. Man hätte auch Champions League spielen können mit ein bisschen mehr Glück. Dann ist das möglich. Und tiefer fällt man nicht mehr, wenn nicht alles total schief läuft. Aber das ist halt auch in dieser Saison passiert. Auch wenn ich jetzt wieder ein bisschen klein rede damit, aber ich glaube, das gehört auch mit dazu.
Und es gehört ja auch dazu, was man an Erwartungen hat. Also ich habe auch gedacht, dass es anders wird als das letzte Mal Europa League. Das war schon klar. Ich hatte auch nicht so viel Angst vorm Abstieg. Aber es war ja dann doch die erste Europa League Saison, also mit Doppelbelastung, die man hatte. Und seit sehr langem hatte. Und ob Streich das so gut macht und so, das war ja alles nicht klar. Und ich wäre mit einem Platz 13 sorgenfreie Saison absolut d'accord gewesen. Also deswegen, das kam dann ja dazu, dass man dann irgendwie, plötzlich geht es nochmal um die Europa League.
Es ging um die Champions League. Bei Union hat man gegen den Viertplatzitten Union gespielt. 0-3 zurückgelegen, dann auf 2-3 verkürzt und dann hat Union, Union hat damals glaube ich auch wieder aus fünf Chancen vier Tore gemacht. Die waren damals einfach das Effizienz-Union. Aber es ging sogar um die Champions League.
Ja, da war ich sogar im Stadion. Einen der seltenen Sachen. Boah, Kevin Behrens war aber auch so krass gegen Brüder. Ja, aber und ich meine, Union war ja ein bisschen das Vorbild. Das war halt das Team, das auch mit der Doppelbelastung gut klargekommen ist. Und ansonsten war es, aber es ist ja gerade für Teams wie Freiburg, Mainz, Augsburg und so weiter etwas schwierig und jetzt, genau, jetzt kommt ja, aktuell hat man ja die dritte Saison, in der das dann fast wieder klappt oder, nee, die zweite Saison mit Doppelbelastung, wo Freiburg um Europa mitspielt. Und ich glaube, das muss man schon sehr hoch bewerten, gewissermaßen.
Ich glaube, es gibt aber auch eine gute Erklärung dafür, warum es diesmal so gut funktioniert und auch besser als bei anderen Underdogs, die nach Europa kommen, weil die Freiburger Idee spätestens seit 22, 23 nicht mehr so sehr darauf ausgelegt ist, wie pressen wir den Gegner und deswegen auch nicht mehr ganz so sehr auf Gegnervorbereitung angewiesen ist, wie in 14, 15, sondern es mehr darum geht, okay, wie kommen wir in unser eigenes Spielsystem, wie kommen wir zu eigenen Chancen. Das Spiel ist auch nicht so kraftintensiv. Man hat mehr Selbstbewusstsein darin. Also gerade letzte Saison war es in der Hinrunde extrem so wie in der Gruppenphase, dass man halt dann im Bundesligaspiel einfach ruhiger aufgebaut hat und einfach mal den Ball hinten laufen lassen konnte, was dann einfach ein bisschen kräfteschonender ist. Und man sieht es auch sehr, sehr gut an der aktuellen Saison, weil das in der Gruppenphase auch noch sehr gut aussah, als man auch dann in der Bundesliga, als man noch relativ gut besetzt war. Und in der Rückrunde, als man auf dem Zahnfleisch gegangen ist, waren die Bundesligaspiele nach Europa League-Spielen, naja, ich möchte jetzt nicht die Wunden aufreißen von einem sehr, sehr fürchterlichen Spiel in Augsburg oder einem sehr, sehr glücklichen Auswärtssieg in Bochum. So schlimm sah das in den anderthalb Jahren davor nicht aus nach europäischen Spielen. Also es hat auch was mit der Umstellung der eigenen Spielweise zu tun.
Vielleicht noch die eine Sache in der Europa League, da sah es halt spielerisch auch sehr, sehr gut aus. Und ich finde, da konnte man auch sehen, was, also Freiburg hatte dann eben die Möglichkeiten, Teams, die ein bisschen blauäugig auf sie zugerannt sind, auch spielerisch auseinanderzunehmen. Und das hat viel auch mit individueller Klasse zu tun und mit Eingespieltheit irgendwie gewisser Weise. Also das ist halt Höfler, Griffo, Günther, Lienhardt, dass sie seit Ewigkeiten zusammenspielen. Und ja, genau, da, das fände ich halt schon immer interessant. Ich glaube, da hat Streich schon einfach diesen Vorteil, dass er lange an einem Standort ist. Ein Vorteil, den eben viele andere Trainer nicht haben, die dann nicht so viel auf alten Prinzipien aufbauen können.
Und sind wir damit jetzt dann auch schon in der aktuellen Saison? Haben wir die jetzt gerade mit besprochen?
Nee, da hätte ich gerne noch einen Punkt dazu.
Aber lass uns ganz kurz da hingehen. Ich mache ganz kurz den Kontext. Kontext Bundesliga habt ihr alle im Kopf. Starke Spitze, eher Schwachs Mittelfeld. Aber endlich mal wieder spielerisch interessant. Also diese Saison passiert halt so richtig was. Worüber wir jetzt aber wahrscheinlich nicht mehr drüber sprechen und wie das Freiburg beeinflusst hat, ich glaube nämlich nicht mehr so stark, wie es früher mal war mit Klopp und so weiter. Genau. Was passiert bei Freiburg? Man hat vielleicht parallel zu der Grottensaison, welche war es? 18, 19. Man hat halt ein schwieriges Transferfenster. Also Flecken geht und die ganzen Transfers, man weiß jetzt diesmal nicht, wer, doch Nyonto ist der neue Cengiz Ünde, der kommen sollte und dann halt nicht gekommen ist. Es kommen Adamu, Muslia, Philipp, aber gerade auch, also Muslia ja erst zur Halbserie und Philipp ganz am Ende und das war schon Plan B. Ja und man setzt auf die Jugend und ähnlich, wie auch bei der letzten Saison, in denen die Sommertransfers nicht funktioniert haben, verletzen sich jetzt halt auch sehr, sehr viele Spieler. Ich weiß nicht, ob man da einen Zusammenhang konstruieren könnte, dass dann halt die Spiele, also dass auf denen mehr Verantwortung liegt, aber naja, es ist halt auch einfach Pech. Also das kann man vielleicht auch nicht bestreiten und ich weiß nicht, also was will man sagen, ich bin mit der Saison aktuell jetzt echt nicht mehr zufrieden. Ich fand die Hinrunde alles noch irgendwie so im Rahmen, jetzt in der Rückrunde, aber da mache ich eigentlich nicht einen Vorwurf. Wenn Günther und Lienhardt halt ausfallen fast die ganze Saison und Günther eine halbe Saison und man dann Europa League spielt, vorne auch immer wieder Leute ausfallen, dann sieht es halt manche Spiele einfach scheiße aus. Also irgendwie, es ist dann immer schwer zu akzeptieren in den einzelnen Spielen und dann denkt man, boah, da muss doch mehr drin sein, aber ehrlicherweise glaube ich, ist gar nicht so viel mehr drin. Das wäre zumindest mein Take. Ich weiß nicht, ob ihr das anders seht.
Ich glaube, meine These ist, dass man inzwischen, wenn man nicht davon lebt, dass man die hohe Qualität der Einzelspieler im Kader alle gleichzeitig aufs Feld bringen kann, ein bisschen darunter leitet, dass man weder ein gutes Ballbesitzteam ist, noch ein richtig gutes Team gegen den Ball, sondern man ist überall okay. Und das sorgt dafür, dass es irgendwie dann, wenn es so viele Ausfälle gibt, wie im Moment, dann oft bieder wirkt. Ich habe auch das Gefühl, da haben wir jetzt noch gar nicht drüber gesprochen, aber was sich so ein bisschen durchzieht durch alle Jahre Streich, ist, dass er nie Chaos stiftet. Also er ist jetzt nicht Markus Gistl oder so. Also für Streich ist Struktur immer wichtig, egal was er spielt. Und das ist, glaube ich, jetzt in der Freiburger Zeit, wo es einfach deutlich mehr Spiele gibt, in denen Gegner zu Freiburg sagen, hey, nimm den Ball und mach was damit. Wird es superschwierig, wenn da keine Spieler mehr drin sind, die das dann von sich aus mit Leben füllen. Weil das wollte ich eigentlich in der Santa-Maria-Saison noch ansprechen und dachte, ich spreche es jetzt an. Man hatte da die ersten Versuche mit 5-3-2-3-5-2 oder auch mit 5-Route-1. Und diese Spiele sehen alle fürchterlich aus bis zum heutigen Tag. Was ganz oft dran liegt, dass ich glaube, dass Streich vor dem Spiel denkt, hey, das sind eigentlich ganz coole Räume, die könnten wir bespielen. Aber er macht den Schritt danach nicht, sondern er gibt nur die Struktur vor. Und dann ist es innerhalb dieser Struktur statisch und Spieler fühlen sich darin nicht wohl und kriegen auch nicht so die Freiheiten aus der Struktur rauszubrechen, weil ihm diese Struktur ebenso wichtig ist. Und dann sieht es einfach nicht so richtig kreativ aus, was mit dem Ball passiert. Ich habe so ein bisschen dieses Thomas Müller-Zitate im Kopf nach dem Leverkusen-Spiel, dass die Leverkusen einfach Bock haben zu zocken und Bayern so ein bisschen nicht oder halt ein bisschen einfach nur Räume besetzt. Und ich finde, das ist ein bisschen Freiburg, diese Rückrunde mit Ball. Man ist in den richtigen Räumen, man sieht auch die Ansätze, aber es sind einfach, bis auf wenn Dorn oder Scholler eine coole Idee haben, passiert nichts. Grifo hat nicht die Form, um das aktuell zu machen. Und das heißt, die Chancen müssten aus der Struktur raus entstehen. Und da ist Freiburg aber einfach ausrechenbar. Die Mannschaften wissen, was kommt, weil Streich es halt wichtig ist, dass seine eigene Mannschaft weiß, was kommt. Und ich glaube, dadurch ist es aktuell einfach ein bisschen zäh. Das wäre meine übergreifende Erklärung.
Ja, und auch deswegen habe ich diesen Punkt gemacht, nochmal rauszukehren, was in der Vorsaison alles passieren musste, damit Freiburg dieses sehr gute Ergebnis hatte. Also das, was man halt jetzt hat, ist eine faire Bewertung vom SC Freiburg. Und die gute Nachricht ist, damit ist man quasi an Europa dran, aktuell in Europa drin, wie auch immer jetzt diese Saison zu Ende gehen wird. Aber du siehst jetzt halt an dieser Spielzeit, was halt passiert, wenn Spieler verletzt sind, wenn Spieler nicht in Form sind und wenn halt in zwei, drei wichtigen Schlüssel spielen, nicht alles so fällt, wie du es gerade brauchst. Und sie haben ja immer noch diese einzelnen Momente, wo mal Grifo und Günther wieder ins Zocken kommen. Oder die Günther-Verletzung ist ja quasi, die hängt ja über dieser Saison ähnlich wie die Günther-Verletzung. Günther und Günther, die beiden Verletzungen, die sind ja so mit die Schlüssel. Und was man aber jetzt dann quasi im Versuch eines ersten vorläufigen Fazits sehen kann, ist, wir beginnen irgendwann 2012 und es nimmt eine Kurve. Es verläuft mal besser, mal schlechter. Man muss auch mal in die zweite Liga. Aber insgesamt wird das Fundament immer stabiler. Es gibt eine langsame Weiterentwicklung. Und ich glaube, in der letzten Saison haben wir gesehen, wo Freiburg hinfallen kann, nach oben hin, wenn eben der Ball immer auf der richtigen Seite des Netzes runterkommt, so wie es jetzt im Tennis wäre. Und jetzt sehen wir gerade, wo Freiburg landet, wenn wirklich viel gegen Freiburg läuft, man ein bisschen Pech hat, Spieler nicht in Form sind, man auch in Heimspielen seltsam schlecht abschneidet im Vergleich zur Vorsaison. Und da ist dann die sehr, sehr gute Nachricht. Ja, naja, gut, aktuell landet man auf Platz 7 und ehrlich gesagt ist es dann für die Gesamtbetrachtung auch egal, ob das jetzt am Ende Platz 9 wird. Ich weiß, dass es für alle Fans und so weiter nicht egal ist und für Julian Schuster. Aber das ist quasi das, was mit Freiburg in all diesen Jahren passiert ist. Und da haben ganz viele Spieler mit zu tun, aber halt ganz sicher auch das Trainerteam rund um Christian Streich, was eben die einzige Konstante war, die immer da war, zusammen mit dem Umfeld. Und wo man jetzt auch, finde ich, im Nachhinein gut verstehen kann, wie das eigentlich passieren konnte, dass Freiburg so Schritt für Schritt für Schritt gegangen ist. Dafür fand ich, war das jetzt nochmal total interessant, das Saison für Saison durchzugehen.
Ja, da könnte man jetzt aber vielleicht am Ende doch sich auch überlegen. Also ich würde sagen, am Anfang ist es sehr, sehr klar, Freiburg, Streich schafft halt eine Überperformance durch den Trainer. Jetzt gerade, genau, vielleicht wäre das nochmal eine Frage, die ich jetzt noch reinstellen würde, bevor wir dann so richtig zum Fazit kommen. Schafft das, also hat das Streich jetzt die letzten zwei, drei Jahre geschafft, mehr aus dem Kader rauszuholen, als drinnen war oder, also ich würde sagen weniger wahrscheinlich nicht, aber ist es so, ist das vielleicht das Freiburger Level auch, das da ganz gut hält?
Ich glaube schon, dass er mehr rausholt, vielleicht nicht im Gesamt-Taktischen oder so, aber weil er halt immer noch ein außergewöhnlich guter Spielerentwickler ist, also wenn man sich anguckt, was Lez Doan für eine Entwicklung gemacht hat in den anderthalb Jahren in Freiburg, Merlin Röhl, wobei da auch Thomas Stamm sehr zu dumm ist bei Merlin Röhl. Boah, wenn ich jetzt anfange, Spieler aufzulisten, dann vergesse ich welche. Genau, also die individuell taktische Entwicklung von einzelnen Spielern, die ist einfach immer noch sehr, sehr überdurchschnittlich, also mehr als überdurchschnittlich, ich würde sagen in der Spitzengruppe der Bundesliga. Und das wird auch das Interessantste sein, ob das ohne ihn funktioniert, weil ich glaube, viele andere Strukturen, bin ich sehr überzeugt davon, dass sie ohne ihn funktionieren. Bei der individuellen Spielerentwicklung weiß ich nie, ist das er als spezielle Person mit dem Jugendtrainer Augenmerk, mit dem immer den Menschen im Spieler sehen, immer nah dran sein an allem, was passiert rund um diese Entwicklung, kann das nur erbringen oder kann das der Standort Freiburg auch mit Julian Schuster? Weil ich glaube, das sorgt eigentlich dafür, dass dieses Team nie so richtig underperformed hat unter ihm, weil er halt die Spieler besser macht und dann ist es auch egal, wenn es mal als Mannschaft nicht so gut funktioniert.
Aber eigentlich ist doch diese Frage nur mit Blick auf die Zukunft wichtig, weil sie einem so ein bisschen die Sorgen nehmen könnte. In der Ritscher ist es doch total egal, ob das jetzt Streich war, der mehr aus den Spielern herausgehutert hat oder ob die Spieler halt einfach eine sehr gute Saison hatten.
Wahrscheinlich hast du da vollkommen recht. Habt ihr noch was zu der Saison oder wollen wir jetzt noch mal zur Abschlussrunde kommen?
Ich möchte vielleicht noch ganz kurz zu der Saison sagen, wir nehmen jetzt ja auf, bevor sie beendet ist und wir nehmen auch vor dem 33. Spieltag auf. Und ich würde aber jetzt das Plädoyer dafür halten, egal wie sie endet. Es war wieder eine sehr gute Freiburg-Saison und auch wenn es ernüchternd ist, wie die Ergebnisse gelaufen sind, vielleicht jetzt auch am 33. Spieltag, ich weiß es nicht, muss man sich das trotzdem noch mal vergegenwärtigen, was mit Freiburg passiert ist. Und man darf deswegen natürlich trotzdem enttäuscht sein, weil es ist ja richtig Ansprüche zu haben oder nicht Ansprüche, sondern Hoffnungen und damit verknüpft auch gewisse Erwartungen vielleicht manchmal. Das ist völlig in Ordnung. Wir wollen natürlich immer nach dem besten Streben. Aber, sich mal kurz zu verdeutlichen, wie viele Vereine haben wir jetzt mal so genannt? Hertha, Schalke, Stuttgart, Stuttgart ist jetzt das eine Beispiel, was es wieder nach oben geschafft hat und so weiter, die aber quasi verschwunden sind zum Teil aus der Liga und nicht wiedergekommen oder halt seitdem nochmal zehn weitere Trainer verpflichtet haben. Aber so richtig auf einem grünen Ast sind die alle nicht. Und Freiburg steht halt einfach top da. Sowohl wirtschaftlich als auch von der Kaderstruktur her, als auch von dem, was die im Kader alle können. Und da ist Christian Streich einer von ein paar Personen, die dafür mitverantwortlich sind. Und deswegen sollte das jetzt schlecht gelaufen sein am 33. Spieltag und vielleicht noch am 34. Spieltag auch enttäuschend verlaufen. Grämt euch nicht. Hört einfach nochmal die Anfangssegmente, die wir hier gemacht haben. Und das ist wirklich eine gute Entwicklung und das ist auch schön, dass das als 50 plus 1 Verein, dass das noch klappt als eingetragener Verein. Das ist doch ein schönes, wunderschönes Gegenbeispiel.
Voll. Ja, das war jetzt eigentlich schon fast ein Plädoyer für die gesamte Ära. Aber lass uns darüber jetzt nochmal so kurz sprechen. Ich teile es nochmal kurz ein. Also wir gehen jetzt vielleicht, also erste Frage wäre jetzt glaube ich doch nochmal, was Streich eingeordnet in der Bundesliga für einen Trainer war. Also weil da nochmal so, ich glaube, wenn man jetzt nicht den Freiburg Schwerpunkt gemacht hätte, sondern wir einfach gesagt hätten, wir gucken uns nochmal die Bundesliga von 2010 bis 2025 an, dann wäre so meine These, Streich würde hin und wieder mal am Rande vorkommen. Aber ich glaube, was wir vorhin auch schon angedeutet hatten, er hat eigentlich keine krassen Trends gesetzt. Oder würdet ihr mir da widersprechen und würdet sagen, es gab Dinge, die Streich in diese Liga eingebracht hat, die wirklich Bundesliga-Geschichte sind, also zumindest für taktisch interessierte Leute.
Ich glaube, dass dieser Fokus, Stürmer laufen an für Deckungsschatten, da habe ich das Gefühl, dass das seit Freiburg das so intensiv gemacht hat, mehr zum Usus gewonnen in der Liga, weil als Freiburg das angefangen hat, Mitte des letzten Jahrzehnts, da haben das wenige Bundesligisten gemacht. Zumindest habe ich es da nirgendwo so richtig bewusst wahrgenommen und inzwischen ist es ja relativ Usus, glaube ich, ein Sechser so zu probieren, ein Spiel rauszunehmen. Außer es ist Karni Csaka und das ist nicht passbar, aber es ist eine andere Story.
Ja, es ist insofern interessant. Ich würde jetzt nicht sagen, dass das jetzt genuin was vom SC Freiburg ist, weil es wurde dann nochmal weiterentwickelt von Hoffenheim, die das dann in Wellen gemacht haben, was auch sehr schlau war, aber was vielleicht durch die Konteraktion dann gut verdeutlicht, dass es doch eine Rolle spielt, weil was machen jetzt Leverkusen und Stuttgart so toll als einzige Teams in der Liga, dass sie warten, warten und warten, bis sie so angelaufen werden und dann über das Zentrum rausspielen. Und auf einmal sind drei Spieler ins Leere gelaufen, mehr oder weniger. Also sprich, es war quasi notwendig, dazu ein Gegenmittel zu entwickeln, mit dem du dann wieder sehr großen Erfolg hast, was zeigt, wie verbreitet quasi dieses Anlaufen ist. Also ich glaube, aus dieser Gegenentwicklung kann man noch mal sehen, war eine wichtige Entwicklung für die Streich schon mitverantwortlich ist, das stimmt. Vielleicht aber auch die Spieler, die er hatte. Also, und das ist der Gedanke, den ich jetzt immer wieder hatte. War es Christian Streich, der die Idee hatte oder war es Christian Streich, der seine Spieler angesehen hat und gesehen hat, ach guck mal, mit euch könnte ich doch das und das spielen.
Das stimmt und da wirklich auch kreativer. Ich meine, so ein Höhler, das ist halt eine Streichkarriere auch. Also, dass der macht die dort und woanders nicht. Und dass man Karim Gede eigentlich als Sechser geholt. Dass der dann praktisch pressender Stürmer wird, war da wahrscheinlich auch da eine Geschichte. Aber ich dachte jetzt einfach nochmal, um Streich halt in Bundesliga einzuordnen, habe ich das Gefühl, er war halt immer so auf der Höhe der Entwicklung, aber er hat sie dann eben meistens doch nicht angetrieben. Das waren dann meistens doch andere. Er war meistens mit vorne dabei, wenn es irgendwie der Kader hergegeben hat. Aber keiner der Trends hätte. Kein Slomcar, kein Rangnick, kein Klopp oder sowas.
Aber muss man da nicht eigentlich eingreifen bei was Max ganz am Anfang gesagt hat? Dass Streich da immer lernfähig war und wie ungewöhnlich das ist für einen Trainer, der jetzt Ende 50 ist, dass es das nicht nur am Anfang seiner Karriere gab, sondern dass er es spricht auch für den Typ Mensch, der er ist, den ich als wahrscheinlich relativ selbst reflektiert wahrnehme, dass er das auch in Bezug auf den Fußball ist, dass er nicht sagt, ich habe das jetzt irgendwie mal 12, 13, hat das gut funktioniert, und das muss jetzt auch 23, 24 gut funktionieren, weil es gibt ja genug Trainer, die halt damals erfolgreich waren und die einfach komplett raus sind aus dem Geschäft, weil die nichts anderes mehr machen können. Also ich erinnere an Mirko Slomka beim Karlsruhe SC vor ein paar Jahren, das war fürchterlich.
Ja, sehr, sehr guter Punkt, weil da finde ich nämlich auch, dass quasi eine Eigenschaft mit erwähnt wird, die jetzt aber ich nochmal gerne explizit ausformulieren würde, nämlich Christian Streich ist nicht nur Trainer, sondern Christian Streich ist auch Videoanalyst. Und diese Personalunion, die man bei ihm hat, die merkst du auch. Und die merkst du nicht nur daran, dass er eben die Vorbereitung macht und eben die Gegner selbst scoutet, sondern dass er das, glaube ich, das interpretiere ich jetzt, macht, weil er eine Freude daran hat, zu sehen, was machen andere. Und weil er das interessant findet zu gucken, was macht denn der FC Augsburg unter Jastorbo? Ach, ist ja interessant. Die spielen jetzt immer die Verlagung Außenverteidiger auf den Achter oder den anderen Außenverteidiger, der eindrückt. Ist ja spannend. Habe ich das nicht bei Union neulich auch gesehen. Und dann hört es bei ihm aber nicht auf. Er überlegt sich natürlich, was mache ich dagegen und wie kann ich das für mich nutzen? Sondern ich glaube, Christian Streich ist da ein Trainer, der sich überlegt, ich habe ja Christian Günther, das könnte ich ja auch machen,. Will ich das? Und dann schaut er, ob es in seine Idee reinpasst, ohne dogmatisch zu sein. Ganz großer Unterschied zu vielen anderen Trainern, die sehr taktisch geprägt sind, die gewisse Prinzipien haben, die sie nicht über Bord werfen wollen. Ich glaube, da ist Christian Streich viel flexibler. Und das ist, glaube ich, etwas, was ihm auch dazu geholfen hat, verholfen hat, ebenso jung im taktischen Kopf zu bleiben. Weil ich glaube, er hat da eine Freude dran, die Gegner zu scouten. Und ich glaube, so wie Leute, die den Rasenfunk hören können oder die den Spodcast hören, eine Freude an taktischer Analyse haben und eben auch quasi sich dran erfreuen, mal über einen Aufbau zu sprechen, so ist Christian Streich auch. Er macht das gerne und übernimmt dann Dinge, die ihm gefallen, entwickelt Gegenkonzepte und bleibt aber deswegen immer im Brüsterzeit. Ich glaube, mit Christian Streich könntest du ein Rasenfunk-Royal alleine zu allen 17 anderen Teams machen. Könnte der aus dem Stand heraus. Und das wäre super interessant.
Ja, interessanterweise ja sogar über die Liga hinaus. Also Atalanta Bergamo ist immer so ein Team, das er häufig genannt hat. Das ist wirklich sehr, sehr gut, was du da ansprichst, weil ich glaube auch, das trifft den Kern wirklich gut. Genau, ich frage mich ein bisschen, warum er das nicht schon von Anfang an gemacht hat, weil das ist ja irgendwie ein Punkt, den ich bei der Vorbereitung so interessant finde. So lange hat er in einer Spielidee festgehalten und hat die im Prinzip nicht abgeändert, auch aus so einer Freiburger Identität mäßig raus. Also wir spielen hier flache Bälle und so weiter. Das gehört irgendwie einfach so zu uns dazu. Und dass er da dann irgendwie drei, vier Jahre braucht, zu sagen, okay, irgendwie muss ich eigentlich mal was ändern. Und ab dort, wo er dann eigentlich so seinen Dogmatismus aufgibt, wird Streich halt eigentlich genau zu diesem flexiblen Trainer, der immer wieder Neues entdeckt und immer wieder Neues dann auch versucht, irgendwie einzubauen, was aber auch gut funktioniert. Und das finde ich eigentlich eben auch interessant. Er macht es halt nicht kopflos. Also der sieht nicht irgendwas und will es sofort ausprobieren, sondern ist ja schon immer das vorbereitet von langer Hand. Hat man das Gefühl, was er da macht. Also man hat eigentlich auch selten so Experimente gesehen, die so einmal aufgetaucht sind, dann wieder weg sind. Das gab es mal hier 4141 gegen Stuttgart oder sowas.
Das waren so Sachen, die es heute der Herr hat.
Es hat auch Spaß gemacht, das zu sehen, weil es so ein bisschen offensiver war. Aber genau, 4141, dieses fünf Router, eins Ding, hat er immer mal. Das merkt man schon. Es gibt so Ideen in der Schublade, die er so ganz selten ausgepackt hat, aber die haben es dann auch nicht so ganz gebracht. Und dann hat er das, glaube ich, auch nicht gemacht. Und da hätte es noch viel mehr Ideen gegeben, aber er ist dann doch nicht so risikofreudig, würde ich sagen. Und das finde ich aber auch gut. Ich glaube, es würde einfach nach hinten losgehen. Es ist ja schon auch immer, dass man die Sachen erst richtig durchdenkt, bevor man sie anwendet.
Ja, wenn wir jetzt den großen Rahmen aufmachen und du meintest, du fragst dich, warum das am Anfang nicht so war, vielleicht ist es tatsächlich in seiner Biografie zu begründen, dass das als Jugendtrainer einfach nie ein Problem war, sondern als Jugendtrainer kriegst du halt jedes Jahr neue Jahrgänge und du kriegst dann auch, deine Gegner kriegen halt auch jedes Jahr neue Jahrgänge. Und wenn du dann halt eine fortlaufende Spielidee hast, die du jedem Jahrgang beibringst, dann also gegnerische Jugendtrainer machen, glaube ich, wenig Gegner-Scouting und dann Anpassungen und so. Das wird mich jetzt sehr überraschend, wenn das passiert. Deswegen war er halt vielleicht einfach ein Jugendtrainer, der immer die gleiche Spielidee verfolgt hatte und dachte, okay, das ist das, was er am besten trainieren kann. Auch weil, also ich komme wieder auf dieses Punkt, selbst reflektiert halt, ich glaube schon, dass er auch irgendwie, dass das auch was mit persönlichem Selbstbewusstsein zu tun hatte, dass er dann sagen konnte, okay, ich kann auch was anderes trainieren, als dieses Spielidee, für das ich stehe.
Sprichst was dagegen zu sagen, dass dieser Umschwung hin von, ich bleibe ganz genau bei meinem System und bei meiner Idee hin zu, ich probiere mehr Dinge aus und bin auch ein bisschen mutiger, spricht was dagegen zu sagen, der Knackpunkt ist der Abstieg und dann die Zweitligasaison, in der er ja zum ersten Mal innerhalb des Systems dann auch große Bestandteile verändert?
Nee, ich würde sagen, das ist genau der Punkt, also dieser Abstieg ändert was. Nicht sofort, sondern es braucht dann ein bisschen in der zweiten Liga, aber da würde ich auch sagen, das ist der Umschwung eigentlich bei Freiburg und ich würde auch fast sagen, man müsste, also es gibt sicher Sachen, die man sieht, die sich von Anfang bis jetzt durchziehen, aber die allermeisten Sachen ändern sich dort und das Team ja auch, also der Kader, der dann irgendwie da ist und lange zusammen bleibt. Ja, Abstieg und Aufstieg sind dann…
Also doch ein reinigender Abstieg oder was?
Also auf jeden Fall, würde ich schon sagen.
Also gibt es noch andere Teams in Deutschland, die aus der Saison 15, 16, vier oder fünf Leute noch im eigenen Kader haben, mit wichtigen Rollen, das glaube ich nicht.
Naja, Bayern halt wahrscheinlich mit Thomas Müller, Neuer und so, ne?
Das Ende der Nahrungskette, das ist manchmal so.
Genau, mit Köln ist jetzt halt Hektor und so weg. Gladbach hatte mit Stindl, also es gibt so ein paar, aber ja, nee, das ist schon was Besonderes und vor allem für Freiburg, die immer viele abgeben mussten. Das ist auch ein bisschen eine glückliche Fügung. Dass Spieler wie Günther Höfler gewissermaßen, ja auch Grifo und so, die Entwicklung genommen haben, dass sich mit dem Verein entwickelt haben. Und ich meine, bei Günther ist ja auch lustig, dass der sich so entwickelt hat, dass dann irgendwann wieder zu Freiburg zurückkommen konnte und Freiburg sich auch so entwickelt hat. Er hatte bei Gladbach noch rechtzeitig den Absprung geschafft. Da gibt es schon so ein paar schöne Fügungen eigentlich. Dass Streich jetzt auch mit so vielen Leuten zusammenarbeiten kann, bis zum Ende.
Ich überlege, ob gerade Stuttgart vielleicht noch eine Ausnahme ist, das könnte aktuell sein. Aber zu diesem Punkt, da ist es natürlich dem SC auch immer zu Gute gekommen, dass die Spieler, die man teuer verkauft hat, die waren selten schlecht dann dort, wo sie hingewechselt sind. Du hast aber immer gesehen, nimm einen Spieler aus dem SC Freiburg raus und der SC Freiburg wird trotzdem weiter existieren und gut spielen. Aber es kann sein, dass der Spieler eine ganze Weile braucht, bis er sich adaptiert hat, dass er jetzt nicht mehr beim SC Freiburg spielt. Also es ist auch, glaube ich, etwas anderes, einen Spieler von einem anderen Verein zu verpflichten als vom SC Freiburg, wo du vielleicht ein bisschen größere Fragezeichen hast, ob das gleich funktioniert. Vielleicht schützt es manchmal auch vor dem einen oder anderen Kauf.
Ja, also gerade die Offensiven, Grifo. Ich meine, bei Philipp könnte man noch streiten. Der hatte auch gute Phasen, aber dann nicht mehr ganz so viele.
Ja, bei den Torhüttern doch auch, mit Ausnahme vom Baumann.
Ja, das stimmt. Ja, die Innenverteidiger, Koch und Zuhönsch, die haben schon gute Karrieren hingelegt. Aber du hast schon recht im Grunde. Machen wir noch kurz die Abschlussrunde jetzt nochmal. Was für ein Trainer ist Christian Streich über die Zeit hinweg gesehen? Was wollt ihr es noch einmal sagen? Wahrscheinlich habt ihr jetzt alles auch schon dreimal gesagt, aber gerne nochmal zum Abschied.
Also ich sag gerne nochmal, er ist ein guter Trainer. Das war's.
Guter Trainer. Wunderbar.
Nee, Christian Streich ist Videoanalyst und Trainer in einer Person. Christian Streich kennt die Liga und offenbar auch den Fußball darüber hinaus sehr, sehr gut. Christian Streich wäre deswegen ein toller Fernsehexperte, wenn ihr mich fragt. Das könnte so ein Jürgen-Klopp-Moment sein, wenn Christian Streich mal irgendwann an irgendeiner Taktik-Tafel auftaucht und mal fünf Minuten kriegt, indem er einfach Dinge zeigen kann. Christian Streich wäre ein ganz toller Gesprächspartner deshalb auch. Und Christian Streich verbindet all das mit sehr vielen Eigenschaften, die er offenbar als Mensch hat, wo man jetzt nur von außen drauf guckt, die wie Faust aufs Auge Arsch auf einmal zum SC Freiburg und seine Umgebung gepasst haben. Und auch deswegen konnte das so lange so gut funktionieren.
Es ist schwierig, was da noch top zu setzen. Ich habe am Anfang was von Pragmatismus gesagt. Ich glaube, das würde ich immer noch hochhalten, weil er schon immer sehr daher kam, was der SC jetzt braucht oder was das Team von ihm braucht. Und das hat er versucht zu geben, so gut er konnte. Und ich glaube, wenn man letztlich in 15 Jahren draufgucken wird –da haben wir jetzt das Beispiel, dass wir in Freiburg auch auf Volker Finke zurückgucken –und bei Volker Finke gucken wir jetzt zurück auf ganz viele Dinge, die er taktisch neu in die Liga gebracht hat, wie er den Fußball auch tatsächlich verändert hat in Deutschland. Und ich glaube, bei Streich werden wir mehr darauf gucken, wie er den Verein im Wachsen begleitet hat, emotional. Wie er dabei dafür gesorgt hat, dass er sich selbst nicht verliert. Das wird eine große Herausforderung in den nächsten Jahren. Und wir werden glaube ich auch sehr viel darauf schauen, wie viele Spieler unter seiner Aufsicht zu Bundesligaspielern oder Zweitligaspielern wurden oder aus anderen internationalen Topdingen. Und die das auch letztlich noch lange Jahre in Interviews ihm verdanken werden, das hört man ja heute in ganz vielen Interviews mit Ex-Spielern von ihm. Da gibt es einfach, vielleicht fragt man die Leute nicht, die eine schlechte Story erzählen würden, aber es gibt sehr wenige schlechte Geschichten von ihm. Ich glaube, das ist das, was von ihm bleiben wird.
Ja, ich glaube, wahrscheinlich gehe ich dann auch einfach in die Richtung, die du gesagt hast. Ich schließe mich euch beiden an. Ich finde es mit dem Videoanalysten sehr, sehr gut. Ich finde es mit dem Pragmatiker auch gut. Und genau, er ist ein Spielerentwickler. Und ich glaube, auch dort sieht man diesen Pragmatismus. Also das hat man in den Pressekonferenzen ja auch immer sehr, sehr gut gehört, dass man in Freiburg, wenn man Spieler verpflichtet, vor allem darüber spricht, was ist denn der Plan mit dir, wenn es nicht gut funktioniert, wenn du nicht voll durchstattest. Und das scheint mir auch immer so eine Sache zu sein, dass er nicht davon ausgeht, dass das Beste passiert, sondern eben sich halt vorstellt, wie Dinge Schritt für Schritt funktionieren werden. Und das konnte man halt bei Freiburg auch immer wunderbar beobachten, wie Spieler nicht voll durch die Decke gegangen sind, sondern sich halt Schritt für Schritt irgendwie verbessert haben. Wie ein Griffhörers geschafft hat, irgendwann gegen den Ball zu arbeiten. Genauso wie ein Petersons geschafft hat, irgendwann mal elf Kilometer zu rennen, was man ihm nicht zugetraut hätte. Dass, ich weiß nicht, Günther irgendwann Flanken schlagen kann, das war oder Standards. Am Anfang alle haben ihn gehasst dafür, dass er das macht. Jetzt ist er halt, jetzt hat er häufig Griffhörerstandards weggenommen. Ja und so weiter. Kann man lange fortsetzen. Das ist dann doch irgendwie noch eine Sache, die sehr, sehr besonders ist. Interessant war es mit Streich. Ist also meine Fußball-Fanzeit voll durch ihn geprägt und durch viele, viele Stunden Pressekonferenz mit ihm. Fand ich immer alles gut, aber letztendlich finde ich es jetzt trotzdem traurig, musste ich mir eingestehen. Der Abschied wird traurig am letzten Spieltag. Und das haben wir noch vor uns. Und dann bin ich gespannt, was mit Julian Schuster passiert. Das können wir dann in zehn Jahren besprechen. Wenn der dann geht, werde ich mal wieder…
Dann lief es sehr gut mit Julian Schuster, wenn wir es erst in zehn Jahren besprechen.
Ja, ich habe an der Stelle kurz eine Podcast-Empfehlung machen. Nämlich an die lieben Kollegen vom Füchsele-Talk, die das große Glück hatten im Februar, glaube ich, Julian Schuster zu interviewen, bevor das große Theater losging um die Streichennachfolge. Das kann man sich sehr gut anhören, wer ein bisschen Vorstand kriegen möchte, was Julian Schuster so ist.
Werden wir in den Shownotes verlinkt haben.
Genau, moderieren ist nicht so meins, aber ihr habt die offenen Enden aufgesammelt. Vielen, vielen Dank. Das war sehr, sehr schön. Zum einen hätten wir da Maxergebost vom Rasenfunk und Elfleben. Nee, da nicht. Nee, nee, das weiß ich. Aber machst du noch von deinem alten Buch Lesung? Oder ist das Projekt jetzt, hast du es hinter dir gelassen?
Wenn mich jemand ganz lieb fragt, dann lese ich noch mit dem Buch.
Wunderbar. Hey, und Patrick, vielen Dank auch, dass du dabei warst. Hat mir sehr, sehr viel Spaß gemacht.
Vielen Dank. Kann ich nur zurückgeben.
Ja, danke euch beiden für die Vorbereitung.
Sehr cool. Wunderbar. Schönen Abend.
Ciao.
Macht's gut. Das war der Rasenfunk. Von Ihnen unterstützt.